the free state project is in full swing
my friends if you've not heard of it you
probably should be following our good
friend luke rudkowski on twitter or his
youtube channel because
i'm pretty sure he's up there right now
he'll be coming back soon but he's a big
fan of this basically the idea is
they want everybody who's liberty
libertarian liberty minded to move to
new hampshire and pledge to support a
free state
and now a state rep has filed paperwork
to
secede from the union
or whatever however you know you got to
be really careful with this stuff
because they're like considering a
proposal drafted to be up for debate or
something like that but basically the
paperwork would put on the ballot that
new hampshire should be a free
independent state it's a sovereign
nation independent from the us
and uh
this is not surprising
we known about the free state project we
know about the people who are moving
there why they're doing it and i got to
tell you as much as there's a lot of
establishment people in new hampshire
going no stop don't
if if the free state project works and
people keep moving there that are
staunch libertarian and our capitalist
or even some people are a narco
communist and like leftists being like
yo we'll take a free sovereign nation
and build our own little commune if all
of the true anarchists and libertarians
do that it's only a matter of time until
you actually have a vote that passes and
you have a state saying we hereby secede
so i'll tell you this as much as this we
can expect there's a lot of stuff going
on in this country that says to me
country's falling apart i mean people
have been predicting divorce there was
this tweet by mike cernovich earlier
where he said something effective it's
the first time in history that the
elites have tried to
subjugate an armed warrior class or like
like take their children or something
like that and we don't know how that
will play out because there's no
historical examples of this and i'm like
it's a good point you know people who
leave the military and they're loaded up
on guns like crazy are not going to sit
back so it's possible
states just start breaking apart we
already have in texas they passed this
bill we're like we're gonna make our own
suppressors and the federal government
has no jurisdiction over this the
federal government atf is like yes we do
and now they're arguing you've got
sanctuary gun laws you've got sanctuary
immigration states
more and more the federal government
seems to be
slowly fizzling in a lot of ways joe
biden comes out and gives it gives his
announcements where he's basically only
speaking to blue states we've seen it
from npr data on vaccination rates in
states the states with the highest
vaccination rates are all biden states
and the states with low vaccination
rates like 40 and below are all red
states so when biden comes out and says
our patients is wearing thin he's
looking right into into the faces of the
people in red states and saying you
better do what i'm telling you he's not
saying to people in the blue states so
that divide it's there so we'll talk
about a lot of the stuff we got we got
some tech stuff to talk about too is a
lot going on with the crypto space so
we're being joined by uh bill ottman hey
hey introduce yourself good friend
what's up everyone i'm bill co-founder
of mindsmines.com
whatever you do don't go to mines.com
there you go
oh you're trying to be your own stuff
we got libby she's back hi how's it
going i'm libby emmons i'm the
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
right on glad to be here oh yeah we have
some stuff to talk about with the
post-millennial oh yeah for sure because
i i was tweeting up a storm about that
vpn company yeah so we'll get into that
the cancer culture stuff yeah they're
coming after andy and you know we'll
talk about that we got ian chilling
hello everyone ian crossland up in the
house good to see everybody
yeah i always love it when we have two
guests the conversation is tough to beat
so i'm stoked for tonight
oh yeah that's a lydia present oh yeah
that's me i press buttons in the corner
before we get started my friends go to
timcast.com become a member to get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast
we're going to have an amazing members
only segment
usually was around 11 or so p.m but
there's a huge library that you need to
understand there's a little magnifying
glass symbol which means search it's
funny it's like an o with a line and
people just know what it means i guess
and you can type in any names we've got
like multiple episodes with with alan
west these are all exclusive to the
website for members so each and every
monday through thursday when we produce
a new member segment the library of
content is getting bigger and bigger
and i think we have like hundreds of
episodes now right that's great so yeah
we have over 300. over 370 so as time
goes on the value of your membership
only gets better plus a bunch of new
shows coming soon you know ian's
beginning to work on his cooking show oh
i'm so excited the joy of cooking with
ian we're not really calling it that i
don't think we can no it's like 100 year
old book oh okay a cookbook yeah that's
not fair the joy of cooking ian
well there we go
that's a little different
all right uh and uh smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if every
single person who was watching right now
took that url and posted it on every
platform on youtube on facebook on their
youtube tab in minds on gab wherever it
is twitter instagram we'd be bigger than
the mainstream media overnight
but i mean like like seriously if we had
like 50 000 shares instantly we'd be
like trending everywhere and people
don't for the most part do it in mass
but you know that's true it's they it
used to be called a thunderclap do you
guys remember that no it was an app yeah
there was a thing where they would do
where would they tell everyone to sign
up and it would it would take the
credential it would like get access to
your to send a tweet on your behalf
and then this app would once everyone
lined up and agreed and they're like a
hundred thousand people it would fire
off a tweet on every account at once
instantly creating a worldwide or global
you know global trend oh yeah smart very
cool i guess twitter doesn't like that
so anyway share the show with your
friends like it smash the like button
whatever let's read this news
ah the world is falling apart
from timcast.com new hampshire lawmakers
consider proposal to secede from the
united states
amazing lawmakers in new hampshire are
considering a constitutional amendment
to secede from the rest of the country
state rep mike sylvia filed a proposal
that would make new hampshire its own
nation state independent from dc quote
there are hundreds of examples of the
federal government overstepping its
authority enough is enough we should put
this before the voters to decide
sylvia cited the usc dc in prevention's
eviction ban joe biden's mandate which
requires federal workers to get the
coveted vaccine as examples of federal
overreach he also mentioned that new
hampshire which has no state income tax
is obligated to pay federal income tax
we are a donor state that pays out more
in federal income taxes than we get back
seceding from the u.s would benefit
residents financially even if it does
mean a loss of federal funding the rep
noted
i want to make this point too
about what they're saying about seceding
joe biden now with the eviction
moratorium he bypassed the legislature
with the supreme court then saying we're
shutting down shutting it down it's
illegal and then him launching another
moratorium bypass the supreme court
now with this vaccine mandate he is once
again bypassing congress we are a nation
at this point so what jack murphy was
saying the other day we're not a
republican anymore
laws are made when the sovereign decrees
and then the plebs are are awarded a
chance
if they are negatively impacted to file
a petition to the courts to challenge
this new law that's the way this
country's been run for the past two
years with all these lockdowns and
everything cuomo killed people yeah
literally literally killed people in new
york city so when new hampshire comes
out and says hey we're done with this
i'm like people need to realize
this is actually fairly serious and i'll
tell you something else something that
had me thinking
in florida for instance where they
banned i think that i'm pretty sure they
banned the vaccine mandate they did
for business establishments
in west virginia we went to the city
called i think was called thurmond i'm
not sure and there was a train station
that was federal property
and there was a man inside working for
the park service
selling stuff
and if you wanted to go in you had to
wear a mask
now here's my question if florida says
you cannot have mass mandates which
they've been in schools i'm pretty sure
i'm not sure about for businesses they
banned it for schools for sure but what
about businesses i'm not sure so here's
here's my point if a federal building
is operating a business that sells
merchandise
in a state that says you cannot legally
do this which means the federal
government is violating the law in the
state
can state troopers go in and
i'm pretty sure shut them down law
supersedes doesn't it and a lot of
people but there's no federal law
mandating masks no it's just a
requirement it's just a presidential
decree so and truth be told in florida
it is also a governor's decree so i
think they it should absolutely go
through the legislature even if it's
rhonda census or abbott my question is
there is no law in the united states
mandating masks so these federal
buildings have no
federal law
saying they should be wearing masks it's
just a politician i'll do it yeah so if
florida does have a law or at the very
least if biden says my mandate is sound
okay then then ronda santa says my my
policy is sound
then what gives the federal government
actors the right to operate business in
the state and under violation of the
state's executive orders well have there
been any confrontations in florida well
that's about it that's so interesting
because so much of this is about
enforcement right right we haven't seen
police are not able to enforce mask
mandates primarily the new york city
police department has refused to do that
kind of enforcement
uh new york city has this vaccine
vaccine mandate thing the new york city
police department is not enforcing it
it's like civilians it's health
inspectors it's random
doofus hostesses at restaurants saying
excuse me like i really need to see your
vox card and id that's what's going on
so
there hasn't been any
violence about it at this point because
there hasn't been any enforcement other
than civilian on civilian enforcement
we saw that in california when they were
doing the lockdowns it was health
inspectors versus like a business owner
you know if you're in a restaurant in
new york you live in new york right i do
if you go in and i don't think you have
experience with this but i'm just
wondering what your thoughts are and
someone says can i see your vac's card
and you say no
what are they gonna do i don't know
because the cops won't enforce it you're
saying yeah the cops are not going to
enforce it i think i think then it's
just a question of like you standing
there saying no
and the person there going well sorry
there was actually a case today we ran a
story about this in the post-millennial
it was this viral video i don't know if
you saw it but yeah yeah it was this
like white restaurant manager owner or
whatever trying to kick a black family
out of her restaurant yes so there's
stuff so it's like systemic racism for
everything except this apparently and
you had the rest of the patrons in the
restaurant saying like oh you need to
show your vax card and he's like we're
not vaccinated and yeah he's citing a
religious exemption but the reason i
brought this up uh in reference to new
hampshire because i don't want to veer
too much off of talking about secession
from the united states
is that you know so i think this family
should move there in this in the civil
war
what kicked it off was fort sumter when
these states were like yo we succeed
screw you and then union soldiers were
still there and the south carolina i
think south carolina was like yo get
your troops out and they were like no
and they said then we're going to force
you out then fight broke out and then a
bunch of other states were like dude
we're out
so if
in one of these red states that has
specifically issued a mandate like a law
or an executive order or whatever saying
you cannot mandate masks
and then there is a federal building
saying we will kick you out unless you
wear a mask
can the state then go to the federal
government say get out you're in
violation of our laws
and i know that's not as serious as
soldiers occupying a base i'm just
saying like their the potential for a
clash between states and the federal
government exists that could be a single
grain of sand that adds to the heap over
time
but i genuinely find that interesting
especially when west virginia has no
mass mandate but these federal buildings
do have one i don't think west virginia
banned stores from having masks and i
don't think florida did that either it's
just kind of a hypothetical if we move
into vaccine mandate territory if joe
biden says that anybody who wants to go
into a federal building has to have
proof of vaccination then you get into
crazy territory with texas and florida
south dakota or whatever where we could
potentially see states say
now we actually want to secede or we
might get an original jurisdiction claim
which would would be like what happened
in the election with all the states
going straight to the supreme court and
challenging the federal government's
authority that would be so it's so
interesting because
we haven't seen any actual clashes
right i mean you know those videos are
coming what do you mean what do you mean
clash between like federal and state no
i'm in between people right between like
we saw the guys shout we saw the people
shouting at each other wasn't there a
nurse who just got
fired and they're there there have been
a lot of yeah the security was having
trying to have her leave there's been a
lot of clashes
there's there's a video right now of a
guy harassing him in a target
he's wearing a pin that says i'm
vaccinated and she's like leave me alone
he's like no and he's following her
around and security's stopping him
there's one video of a guy stalking a
woman and he goes is anybody else mad
that we have to wear a mask and she
doesn't
that's the thing too it's like once
you've accepted the
the
tyranny upon yourself
and then you really need to enforce it
on others just to make sure that you're
not the fool right
and that's that's kind of a problem
we have that going on i was uh so
i was uh i saw this post from this guy
theater company situation in san
francisco and this guy was complaining
that he had gone to a theater
performance and there were people who
took their masks off once the lights
went down
and he complained to literally everybody
and he started saying he wrote this
whole post about it and it was uh he was
saying that
these people not masking ruins the
experience for everybody else and he
complained to the theater company and
the ushers and the patrons themselves
and literally everyone and he took it
online not even realizing that he's the
one who's ruining this he can't just
live and let live if he wants to you
know wear a mask or a tie or a belt
whatever that's his issue in that video
you brought up where it's the black
family and he's like yo this is
segregation he yells out something like
is this the country you want to live in
and someone yells yes yeah people were
like yes like
they like the boot it's horrible it's
just and it's it's terrifying to watch
this happen and to watch civilians
that's the thing that i find so
horrifying about it is the way that the
enforcement works so in new york city
this vaccine mandate thing it's
there's no cops doing it there's you
know maybe the random health inspector
is going to show up and you're going to
have situations where you know somebody
accidentally gets let in and it's like
the you know serving people without
proper id situation or whatever but
that's what we're looking at so
i've talked to a bunch of people about
it and they say they don't know how to
push back against it because it's just
pushing back against somebody else who
is being pushed by the same rules i i do
not accept that i don't understand yeah
well it's it's it's what people are
looking at they don't know
do you show up at
the starbucks that's making you wear a
mask with your with your gun like what
do you do no you just don't wear a mask
you don't wear a mask you don't show
your vaccine card and the person says at
the restaurant okay then you can't come
in and you do so what do you do you just
walk away you just don't
so it leads also to people
self-segregating themselves out of
society
i think that when someone when someone
says oh but i'm being forced to do it
too it's like you're not no you're not
you're not being forced to do it you're
just choosing to do it because you don't
want it you don't want to deal with you
don't you don't want to be responsible
or you don't want to lose your job
i just don't think they'd lose their job
either so the person at the restaurant
says show me your vaccine card and show
me your id and you say no and they say
i'm not going to let you in what do you
do do you just walk past them and sit
down
you don't go there don't don't give
money to businesses that are willing to
enforce it i get it yeah but how do you
even know which ones are going to
enforce it until you show up
they're all going to say yes
uh there so i called 25 one of them said
no okay
one of them was like i don't know uh no
i think that's fine i'm not maybe they
just didn't realize what was going on
because they didn't pay attention that's
possible but but uh
go there and
you know here's what you do it's really
really simple you go to your bank you
take out as much money as you can in
cash then you walk you you get you put
on a stove pipe pad or whatever in a
tuxedo and you walk up it's twirling a
cane and and knock on the door and you
walk in and you've got all the cash in
your hand and you're flipping it around
and when they're like you have a vex
card oh oh no i don't but look at all
this money i was going to spend and then
when they kick yo go i guess you don't
want money i'm kidding don't actually do
that they they don't though they don't
want you no they do there was a bunch of
restaurants that have been complaining
there was a story where a journalist
went around asking they said revenues
are down 25
and they can't handle this it's
destroying their businesses and i'm just
like if you still live in new york after
literally everything you've seen i'm
gonna put my feet back
grab a drink and just laugh
yeah well i mean there's somebody who
lives in new york like
it's sort of you know i how about don't
how about don't but
i mean we have real world data now that
psychologists are going to have an
absolute field day with because this is
like what you know all of the classic
studies on obedience were based around
and now
there's just data everywhere in real
world information there's going to be
crazy studies that happen based on all
of all these events we live in a
simulation we destroyed our entire
social sciences no no we live in a
simulation and this is the purpose to
see how many people would just be like
you hit me harder daddy to gather data
for the simulator but we already saw
that that was like the whole first half
of the 20th century oh yeah i know we
said hit me harder daddy until i bleed
please but maybe
maybe maybe the test is
with the history knowing this
can you know what happens to a
population with a history of negative
consequences to authoritarianism what
happens when you then reintroduce
authoritarianism to
a population that knows it
and we can clearly see
i i that's why i call it a cult you know
these are people who just believe
whatever they hear on tv it's like lies
all the time
they they say like i trust the science
it's like you didn't even read it
they're like doing they criticize people
who do research like all you did was
read a few articles did you do a double
blind controlled study and it's like no
and you didn't even read the articles
it's like you've done less than i have
so those people in mass
are
are in these are demanding vaccine
mandates cheering for it
and we got we got so much on this stuff
i'm saying this this is why we started
with the new hampshire seceding from the
union thing because i'm like yo this is
all just gonna fall apart you ready for
this here you go libby you live in new
york city right i do
de blasio rolls out covet booster shot
plan utilizing all nyc vaccination sites
we're ready
so it's only a matter of time until
you're the person at the restaurant with
them saying do you have proof of
vaccination and you show them and
they'll go this only has two on it right
yeah and you're going to be like but i'm
vaccinated yeah but now we're doing
boosters yeah i know to be fair that's
what's going on the current mandate is
for at least one shot right so it's
going which is funny isn't it new york
new orleans san francisco and la
the funny thing is uh and then all of
california probably they're saying it's
a vaccine mandate
but you don't have to be fully
vaccinated
so my my question there is is one shot
enough it's just because it's about
compliance it's only about compliance
yeah you can you can a a vaccine card is
not a negative cova test you can you
could actually have a vaccine card have
been vaccinated contract covid and then
go to this restaurant show them your
vaccine card and sit down like that you
see the story about that lady the thing
with the antibodies right so if you've
had covid and you have a natural
immunity that doesn't count which is
absurd yeah right that's just absurd and
for big events i was just at a music
festival in greenwich and basically you
know unvaccinated people were required
for a test to have a test and vaccinated
we're not required to have a test i mean
why wouldn't everybody be required to
have a test because everybody can spread
it so like that is a core hypocrisy
everyone should have to get tested if
everyone is still spreading it right how
is that controversial did you see that
story about the woman who was vaccinated
but got covered and died from it and in
their obituary they were like she was
vaccinated but was infected by someone
who chose not to be and it's like well
you don't know that like breakthrough
cases are rare but they happen she got
one maybe she got it from somebody who
also had a breakthrough case just making
that up but this is the craziest thing
when they say stuff like we must protect
the vaccinated from the unvaccinated and
i'm like i don't understand what that
means because you can get that but so
the response from many of these people
on the left has been we're saying that
the unvaccinated are loading up hospital
beds and congesting you know the
hospitals and i was like oh so we should
protect the fit from the fat
so fat people should get the boot from
the from the hospital for triage for
only the healthy people well and of
course that was mayor michael
bloomberg's thing when he was the
mayor of new york he had he wanted a uh
i think he passed it there was like an
extra tax on big gulps yes right yeah i
don't know if that yeah i asked and then
it got repealed a year later yeah yeah
yeah i know he was there for a minute
he's the guy who famously said tax the
poor
unironically literally said poor people
are too stupid to know what to buy so if
we take their money from them and buy it
for them they'll be better off
yeah i don't see how this country stays
i'm having a bit of a problem when
they're like the vaccinated people are
can maybe contract it from the
unvaccinated but it's also from what
i've learned in the animal population so
technically someone could contract it
from an animal like a dog i don't i
don't know about that we talked about it
before yeah and people have mentioned
animal what's called animal uh reservoir
yes yeah so that covet can be
transferred it means cats and stuff but
i know it can be in bats but i think i
think there was something that was a
study or whatever or an article that
said when it does transfer to animals it
doesn't transfer back but they said
people got it from a bat right
if that's the case then there you go and
and so that's the there's chinese
studies that it's in ice cream like
you keep bringing that up no because
they did one article about it and where
did it go is in the in the food supply
people need to understand that ian eats
a lot of ice not anymore
[Laughter]
count me out
well that's why the origin does matter
in an uncensored public debate about
everything related to this because
that's what science is science is a
public debate that has access to the
full spectrum of information so for
anyone who says that they defend science
but they're all about getting rid of
misinformation well actually uh you're
not really helping the scientific
process to play out well that's the meme
it's like we believe in you know all of
the scientists agree and then a
scientist goes actually i have something
to say and they go banned from social
media all of the scientists agree
so you've got a bunch of doctors that
have been talking about alternative
therapies and stuff but they get banned
from every every platform so it's like
when they say a doc this is what i love
i keep i keep telling people like go go
see a doctor you trust don't just take
it from celebrities or tv doctors
and it was really funny when
leftists started attacking me for that
and i'm like why are you mad at me and
they're like you're just scaring people
it's safe they should go to the parking
lot at the 7-eleven and get their
vaccine from the you know the pop-ups
that they do and i was like they should
talk to their doctor first and then go
to the pop-up and they're like no
and you know why because some doctors
might give you better more personalized
advice and oppose their political
medical opinions well these are the same
people who
definitely don't want women to see
ultrasounds before they go through with
abortions they really don't want women
to see that oh yeah so they oppose those
laws and then you know because if you
see an ultrasound i was pregnant one
time
and you see the ultrasound and it's
crazy you're like oh my god that's my
baby
that's what texas does life texas
requires that they really complain about
that stuff like forcing you to see an
ultrasound it's like forcing you to see
the life inside your body strange how
crazy what are you gonna do when the
booster happens in new york oh i'm not i
don't think i'm gonna get a booster
cause there's been a bunch of studies
saying you don't need it i don't have
any interest in getting it
um but then what do you do
what happens when they're like fully
vaccinated now means booster shots every
five months i don't know you know i
gotta say you can leave i'm at like i'm
sort of at a total loss i keep uh
i keep looking for other places to live
you know what it is it's interesting i
don't have anything tying me to new york
i used to have a lot of things tying me
to new york
like lots and lots of things and now i
have like
there's no reason for me to be there
uh there's also no reason for me to be
anywhere else i basically have no reason
to be anywhere at all there is a reason
there but there is a reason so much to
do there's a reason to be somewhere else
but which other else which else well
hold on which else should i be in
montana that works montana you're closer
to canada and those post-millennial
peeps right yeah they're in vancouver
right no they're they're in quebec oh
really like northern new hampshire you
speak french not
there's a really super volcano on mine
well
oh really yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh uh
andy knows up in portland
i go to bozeman yeah that's a college
town i'm sure it's very blue yeah these
are options i will put them on the map
you should see my map it's ridiculous i
could go here i could go there
i mean the other thing too that i uh
i've only ever lived in the northeast
right like i've lived in
i've never lived in maine
kind of nice maine's great
went up to maine with bill one time on
vacation the water is freezing well sure
yeah
and they have black flies
those big things they bite you
they have green ones in new jersey you
know what they do they
they when they bite you it's not really
quite a bite at first it's like these
little scissors
scissors jaws and they slice away at
your
skin
and then they bury their face inside and
suck your blood out that way that's why
the bite hurts so much oh yeah it's not
like a little needle it's like snitch
in there wow those are like those black
mosquitoes they look engineered have you
ever seen one of those up close they
look like robots or the ones with like
brooklyn it's like the the the patterns
on them oh i don't have seen that
they're little stripy things those
things yeah i think that's they're like
they're terrible they're like leopard
mosquitoes what do you think if you if
they're dr seuss mosquitoes if you go to
maine
right you're in the northeast and you
can get a big plot or hey wait a minute
new hampshire hey new hampshire do you
know i have a lot of family there there
you go look at that so you got reason to
leave new york and reason to be in new
hampshire perhaps and you can do
whatever you want for the most part you
can have chickens
chickens we're big fans
the biggest
has there been any form of an actual
secession
in
common you know memory or in the u.s or
like anywhere no anywhere part of idaho
is trying our part of oregon is trying
to get to idaho when did the whole
sudanese thing happen with sudan and
south sudan that was probably i mean it
was a while ago yeah so probably not in
our lifetime unless look i'll be honest
with your chats yeah i wouldn't know
what job in my head i'm sure a lot of
people are gonna be like oh yeah i look
at these countries and look at that
there's a bunch of different people
across the united states trying to
succeed you've got the state of
jefferson you've got a
district in colorado trying to join
wyoming the czech republic and slovakia
they split up oh yeah that's right we
had all kinds of eastern bloc stuff that
was what 90 oh yeah 92 93 the soviet
union collapsed there you go okay we had
all of those all of those baltic states
but it's not the same thing no like
i guess it is i guess once they just
break apart the union no longer exists
well it's it's definitely different the
united states is different it it's
different worldwide right when the us
um the us is the beacon of freedom it's
all of these things that we
american exceptionalists say that it is
and it's these things in part because we
say it is and it's these things in part
because of our history when the u.s if
the u.s crumbles if the u.s loses
freedom and liberty then the world loses
those things it's not just us it's our
entire world
i just want people to realize something
i want to imagine something i mean
australia is not a free place right we
we we know that the people
you know i love to cite the the poll on
economics that democrats think the
economy is doing fairly well but
independence republicans think it's
doing fairly bad which is objectively
true especially with the latest like
inflation numbers and and all that stuff
and the forecasting down to the gdp and
things like that which jackson says is
still pretty good but anyway i digress
i want you to imagine
these people who live in california who
voted for gavin newsom
they adamantly believe
you are in a death cult and it's funny
because you'll see it on reddit you'll
see it on twitter they say these people
are in a death cult and you're like it's
really weird how
in this political faction we can have
liberals moderate centrist conservatives
religious folk all having discussions
and debates on a variety of issues
all disagreeing but agreeing on liberty
and principle and then being told
they're in a cult and then you have the
completely homogeneous
faction on the left believing they're
not in the cult but they just believe
whatever they're told on tv my favorite
is when you go to like r slash politics
on reddit and there will be a headline
that's an outright lie and if you
actually click the article you'll see
it's not true but all of the comments
are like ruthless smart and it's true so
i want you to imagine those kind of peop
those people
then i want you to imagine an actual
conflict breaking out
and they're telling themselves and their
friends and their families the dangerous
trump death cultists
are trying to take this country and we
have to stop them the insurrection all
of that stuff which they genuinely
believe
yeah they're gonna fight they're gonna
fight believing that they're right and
then
people like us are gonna be sitting here
being like yo a bunch of crazy people
are trying to
push crazy nonsensical things on
everyone else
the point i'm trying to make is
there is no remedying the divide it's
impossible
it's not it's not possible i mean that's
a that's an extreme statement
it might be possible i'm thinking about
about hitler abusing the media to drive
people crazy and and radicalize people
and now the media has driven people
craziness radicalizing people but
there's no hitler there's no there's no
cult leader they they get away they
don't need it anymore somehow they don't
think they didn't need it occult leader
let me let me let me pull up this story
and then i'll go into detail um this is
from reuters pelosi predicts what's his
name would fail in 2024 house run well
that's the headline but i think they
bury the lead at the end of the article
we see we see this
i say to my republican friends and i do
have some take back your party pelosi
said you have now been hijacked by a
cult that is just not good for our
country dude there's no there's no
remedy in this nancy pelosi is what
she's 80 years
old she's 82. she is as crooked as they
come joe biden got a prosecutor fired in
ukraine because he was i won't say
because but he was investigating barisma
a company his son was on the was a board
of director on one of the board of
directors
joe biden flew his son on air force two
to china to negotiate a private equity
deal joe biden
just when he was put in charge of iraq
all of a sudden his brother gets these
lucrative contracts for doing
construction in iraq the dude is as
crooked as they come we know it and
pelosi has the nerve to say that
everyone else is in the cult you cannot
convince pelosi voters who keep
empowering that crooked corrupt behavior
that they are empowering crooked look at
this gavin newsom just won yeah they
won't even recall a guy who says you're
not allowed to go outside but i'm going
to go to a restaurant without wearing a
mask i think they just really like his
hair yeah i think
we're dealing with
with npc lemming type whatever the look
but you see penn gillette sitting there
with with newsome giving a thumbs up
these people have gone insane penn
jillette was it was a cato libertarian
yeah he was a question authority guy and
now he's sitting there with the guy
who's ruling by decree with a thumbs up
happy it's happening they've lost their
minds well they're using crisis as a
reason to abandon our traditions and our
representative government and they're
saying that because it's a crisis we now
get to abandon all the rules and do
these executive and you know overarching
things and what's being missed of course
is that it's during a crisis it's when
things are at their most dire that you
have to hold fast to your principles and
to your values and to your traditions of
government for sure what we need is a
representative government and what we
have is executives all over the country
making their own determinations even the
governors where i agree with what
they're doing which i would say in a lot
of cases i agree with desantis i agree
with some of abbott's stuff as well
i don't agree with how it's being done i
think it's being done in a completely
garbage way it's being done in a way
that undermines the very values of our
nation
and it's not okay it's just not okay but
you said also that these people are
gonna fight right these like uh
the new some supporting pelosi types
right they're not going to fight no no
no no they're going to get the
government to fight for them and then
what's everybody else and who are the
people who are in the police departments
and in the army it's those people
because right now in the army you have
that lieutenant colonel who resigned and
said i will not abide by this tyranny i
will not stand for the critical race
theory
all of these like
rational thinking individuals are like i
am out who will be left holding the
weapons
so i'm not saying you're average sitting
at home filling out a mail-in ballot
gavin newsom supporter is going to be in
the streets yelling and you know
flinging torches or something
but
a decent percentage of these people who
go march in the streets with the cop
doing the communist salute the red
salute while they're protesting
those people will fight antifa will act
as partisan engaging in violence
to to gain political power and territory
the police who remain are gradually
becoming more and more pro-establishment
authoritarian the libertarian-minded
people are quitting and resigning from
the military and the police departments
so it's only a matter of time well
there's also parallel economies and
governments that are being formed right
now in crypto and like the crypto
economy that is forming in parallel is
actually the funny part you know you
brought up uh anarcho communists and
libertarians in the beginning like in
new hampshire they both support bitcoin
and crypto because it's a fair sort of
you know
permissionless system that anyone can
participate in so there are actually
proposals for network states like balaji
who's a you know really interesting
crypto uh
character
has proposed the idea of a network state
and so like we have all the typical
geopolitical stuff happening but we also
have a crypto digital situation forming
this is the the piece of the puzzle
people need to understand
when you bank we were talking about this
in the members segment last night when
you bank there's no money it's a ledger
that's how your bank banking works i
talked to my bank after there was an
error and there's a problem and they
basically said we write down that you
have this number and then when you say
you you want to transfer it we erase the
number and the other bank writes down
you have the number money never
exchanged right
cryptocurrency
is an alternate decentralized ledger
that allows funds to to move around the
world
outside of the us financial system
if there was going to be any kind of
conflict in the us it would require
support means of communication and
funding and with decentralized
communications becoming more and more
prominent particularly when we see
crypto
the us government can let's say you get
to the point where people are fighting
in the streets they are but i mean like
overt political factions with new flags
new hampshire secedes the federal
government's moving in and they say
we're going to cut off all their bank
accounts we're going to seize their
funds and seize their assets and they go
this is new hampshire
we use bitcoin here you can't do
anything to stop it
this allows people to exchange value
outside of the us government and it
strips the us government of the ability
to do anything about it which means
resistance can be funded
so if people whether it's antifa
claiming to be the resistance they'll
get funding through crypto a lot of
these alt-right dudes we're getting
massive amounts of money through crypto
the government has no customs but antifa
too that's what i'm saying and yeah and
and that's an important thing and i
think it's important not to you know
make it like government versus crypto
because that's really not what the
situation is we just saw el salvador you
know bitcoin is legal tender in el
salvador now we want to encourage the
u.s to adopt bitcoin because that is in
the interest of the us it's going to
make the u.s stronger no it isn't yes it
is no it isn't absolutely the u.s has
one export you know we were talking
about this before it's the petro dollar
okay that's fine and that's going to be
happening but you know they they can't
stop the momentum so you know so it's
very very bad for u.s hegemony that we
that we will lose the petro dollar
that's fair but you want to be
you know
ready for the next evolution and if
you're not that's why like a lot of
investors will simultaneously
fund the competitors to their own
investments yeah imagine their bet yeah
it's like when you go to the roulette
table and you're like you get you've got
first and you know you know the first
second and third quadrant so you bet on
two of them hoping that it's like a
greater chance of winning but you win
slightly less that's basically what it
is bill tell me about this network state
thing because i've been thinking about
something well i don't know too much
about but so we have daos which are
decentralized autonomous organizations
where people are essentially
voting with crypto tokens on various
proposals around different projects and
the projects are governed by
the token holders of the project and
it's all you know cryptographically
secured and it's a public ledger and so
you could you know when you talk about
systems for voting
you know why not move voting systems to
cryptographic systems i mean that's
obvious so and that's really what
there's still a lot of challenges there
oh yeah yeah like how do you how do you
get someone how do how does someone
register into the system to be able to
vote using crypto
well there would have to be some sort of
connection between the decentralized
identity like in the crypto wallet tied
to like a driver's license so that you
know if a state was actually going to
become like a network crypto state then
it would have to be sort of connecting
its its databases identities with the
actual crypto addresses how do you clean
voter rules
like clean what do you mean people die
yeah you have to get people off the
rules and then all the point yeah and
then all of a sudden you've got ids like
someone passes away and then a week
later someone's like i got access to
their crypto and you know so so it's a
good no there's definitely edge cases
that have well i i i do think
there is some you know we should leave
people are voting now anyway but yeah
well there was like uh
what was it like a couple dozen people
were found in one particular
jurisdiction but that i don't want to
make it seem yeah i i don't know
millions i'm just that's a name well
there was an old joke in philadelphia
which is notoriously shady uh
politically and there was a
long-standing republican on his death
bed and his best friend is this
democratic operative and the guy says
you know well at least as he's dying at
least i never voted democrat and his
friend says don't worry you will
that's terrible yeah i heard that joke
like 25 years ago i think
there is some promise with crypto in
terms of voting but i do think we can't
overlook the fact that
let's say new hampshire does because
they want to put this thing on the
ballot new hampshire wants to see it
and in 2022 people will be able to check
off yup we want to succeed now
apparently a bunch of establishment
people are like no it's bad we don't
want to do this let's say they do
they don't got to worry about funding
they don't got to worry about being cut
off they don't got to worry about the
federal government being like we
sacrifice blood and treasure free admits
to the union and we will not let you
leave they'll be like what are you gonna
do about it we get our funding through
decentralized internet you know networks
we fund each other and people in new
hampshire are armed to the teeth
so what i mean what would really happen
in circumstance would the feds storm in
the national guard the army and try and
shut the state down and usurp civilian
authority they would fight for i-95 i-95
runs through vermont um and it connects
maine and what's the one right south of
there south of maine maine and
massachusetts they would sanction they
would block off their portland yeah they
take they try to the federal government
will try to take i-95 back and shut the
camera from the coast how would they how
did they take the how would they change
the coast
you think they oh yeah
if someone tried to secede from the u.s
they'd bring up the entire for the
entire military force to stop it okay
now i really want to see this i'm not
convinced
what else can you do if someone tries to
leave your union i mean you have to as a
government look at brexit
yeah they didn't do it they couldn't do
anything about it that was europe but
but still like we're at a point where
like even scotland if if scotland really
did vote for independence what can they
do are we gonna see a whole another
campaign to go claim scotland for the
crown the only reason i think they're i
think they're uh working on that right
right right so my point is
we are beyond the era of violence
within to a certain extent what i mean
is
people will not tolerate
conflict and so if new hampshire says
here's our list of grievances here's the
problem and then images start emerging
of like new hampshire residents being
beaten and dragged the rest of the
country would be like stop stop what are
you doing this is bad we don't care
about new hampshire the federal
government would freak out but people in
idaho are going to be like whoa
i'll tell you this if people in new
hampshire really did vote to secede
and it was like boom there it is we have
people mentioning super chat they have
it in their constitution that they can
then if the federal government moves in
a bunch of other states are gonna
file lawsuits they're gonna make
declarations
basically what happened in the original
civil war the original the first one in
the united states the original i like
that several states seceded from the
union
the union union soldiers were at fort
sumter
and when conflict started i think it was
seven more states that went whoa we're
out we're done the moment you started
attacking
states that yeah i see i-95 as fort
sumter if they try and block the road
from massachusetts to maine by taking it
to a new country then the government
would try and take it back and that
would be like there's another thing too
which is
southern new hampshire is mostly just a
bedroom community for boston
so
a lot of people who live in that little
southern new hampshire area that borders
on massachusetts work in boston or work
in
massachusetts um and i don't think they
want to get cut off from their jobs i
think i don't think they want to like
lose their jobs because they can't get
across the border if there's some sort
of issue
let me say i'm not going to i'm not a
historian to tell you about the soviet
union or anything like that but they
lasted i think 69 years and then
collapsed they broke apart the united
states we got like 250 a little bit more
than that
it's possible that they're that we we
suffer a similar dissolution when i'm
thinking of network states i was
visualizing like a way for us to vote
across a network for things that aren't
local because localization has changed
now you can have a conversation with
anyone anywhere um it doesn't matter
and so
that we would we would have a system of
voting where i could vote alongside
someone in north dakota
for something that goes on in in texas
but then if the power goes out we
default back to this local system or we
could have both those systems in
parallel because the united states is
changing and it will
are you thinking of like something more
along the lines of a
completely direct democracy where
everybody votes on everything that'd be
terrible no not necessarily you could
still have a representation if you
wanted but more of a
an interconnected system of voting that
isn't based on where you live it's it's
based on what you do and so the people
that do certain things could vote on
that thing
and you know the problem you know the
problem is
uh the system of government they have
that we have is is beyond brilliant i i
reflect on the us government i'm just
like man did these dudes work it out so
you look at
the reason we we vote the way we do we
have districts we've got counties
is that we want to protect
say there's a small town that's got a
water reservoir and the people all move
there and they share and they bask in
this water and they protect it and then
a neighboring county says we want it we
want to vote to take it so we actually
have a weighted vote system with the
electoral college to grant some
protection some defense the united
states has the ability of minority rule
you know two uh democracies two wolves
and a lamb deciding on what's for lunch
republic is a well-armed lamb contesting
the vote
so that's that's really really important
the problem is
we've become a completely nationalized
information economy so where it used to
be that your local news outlet had your
city that you would learn about they
still exist for sure
now people are increasingly increasingly
getting their news from national sources
there was a joke i think it was i think
it was 30 rock actually because i've
been watching it where they were like
and now back to national radio that
doesn't make sense for you because we're
it's it's hot out there or maybe it's
not maybe it's cold it could be
and so
what happens then is people vote based
on these
overtly national issues
so when you talk about you've talked to
ian before you ian you've talked before
about
direct democracy in a republic system
meaning
i think what you mean is we still have
the jurisdictions we still have a
defense for a minority for minority you
know smaller less populated areas to
have their votes heard but instead of
sending a representative they just issue
a county yes or no yeah as opposed to
having a report a direct republic the
problem with that is which is
interesting is that these people aren't
paying attention to their local issues
anymore so when nestle comes in and
starts guzzling up all their water and
destroying it they don't know about it
so then when there's a vote put up where
it's like should nestle be allowed to
take water from reservoirs they go sure
why not
and then it's like oh wait that's our
water i didn't know that because we
don't pay attention locally anymore so
that's
regardless of whether they use your
system or anything else that is one of
the key problems right now like aoc
would not have gone elected gotten
elected or re-elected were it not for
the fact that she's got donors all over
the country in small pockets funneling
money into her district which she's
supposed to represent but she represents
the interests of a mass of twitter
socialists yes that's right
i i don't really see her representing
much of the bronx no i mean
menstruators
i tell you this go to the birthing
people of the bronx right i mean she's
at birthing people right yeah she's like
go into the bronx her and corey bush go
up to a latina mom and ask her as a
birthing person how she feels about you
know gang violence and she'll be like
what she might laugh depends on how you
say it but yeah i think she'll say what
okay yeah and you'll be like birthing
person you know aoc
is a congress birthing person
no one talks like that and she's not
representing the people of her district
the problem is these people don't know
or don't care and they vote for it like
nancy pelosi said
people would vote for this glass of
water if you put a d on it that's it
that's what she said that's what she
said about her district and aoc's you
put a d on a glass of water and people
will will elect it the uninformed voting
how do you solve that now that's another
conversation completely the the thing
about the uninformed voting is we've
completely crippled crippled our
educational system so it's not like
people are learning anything in schools
at this point
we have uninformed voters i think by
design
oh yeah schools are just
in fact i think that's part of it
let me let me tell you where we're at my
friends we got the story i want to pull
up
quote we need to stiffen our spines and
lean in to keeping people safe
and healthy governor newsom says his
recall success proves democrats need to
get tougher with covert restrictions
so there can be peace awesome they're
going to give us that last part i added
that wasn't in the headline
but uh yeah so basically what happened
was uh since the recall failed
gavin newsom stood up before the the
state legislature in california and says
the attempt on my governorship has left
me scarred and deformed and i will
reform california into the first you
know
state state state empire it's just the
government's responsibility to keep us
safe that's not their job that's not
what they that's not what they've been
tasked to do by the voters that's not
what they were tasked to do by
you know the founding fathers who all
managed to find themselves in the same
place at the exact right time but here's
here's the issue
they tried to recall newsome and a bunch
of conservatives said he's going to now
punish the people of california with
harsher lockdowns and he's doing it and
he's going to i mean right after the
election that's when la put in place
their
vax pass yeah rules they waited till
right after the election i i got to be
honest i really do think that like
newsom was sitting in his office like
this you know looking at the tv and then
when cnn was like we caught a wolf
blitzer comes on it looks like a
landslide victory for newsome he went
yes
that's how i imagine the guy yeah that's
a really good evil villain laughs i was
just trying to imitate great doctor
yeah that's what he did yeah that's good
and then everyone around him was like
they're laughing yeah that's that's how
i imagine it because now he's like
you know just imagine gavin newsom
looking over who's the lieutenant
governor and he's like can we put more
lockdowns on los angeles let's punish
the people there let's make them like
really hurt that would be fun that's
what de blasio's doing i think it's
intentionally punishing new york city
did they ever get the sand out of the
skate park they didn't they did yeah
yeah that was cool i'm surprised
skateboarders didn't show up with like
leaf blowers and start blowing it out
but they did go there and sweep and i
feel like vacuum would be more effective
yeah but isn't it isn't it isn't it how
like how crazy is it that people still
want to live in these places
i guess the issue is
a dumb population is an easily
controlled population yeah i don't know
why anyone would willingly move to new
york at this point or california or
really any of those illinois
i was talking to a family member
and there my family's in chicago and
they said it's it's miserable it's awful
like it's it's worse than it's ever been
like is it a crime or is it no no it's
the lockdown there's lockdowns in
chicago yeah so it i don't know exactly
what's going on um but i have family in
the suburbs and they're like everyone's
like you you can't you can't go anywhere
without a mask they've got mandates
popping up all over the place the
schools are freaking out it's like
authoritarian nightmare in brooklyn it's
back to everybody walking around with
masks on outside yeah like fools and i'm
just walking around like a normal person
without my mask on because why because i
was i i've done the vaccination i've
done the thing that they said and it's
just it's never enough it's never going
to be enough let's talk about doing the
thing there's two americas right now
in new york people walk around outside
wearing masks in west virginia people
walk around outside wearing their ar-15s
which one would you want to live in no i
mean this seriously though obviously not
everybody in west virginia is walking
around with like a rifle and they're
like looking around but there are people
who do that we went to uh uh we were
driving through virginia and virginia's
not a good example but we're on our way
to central west virginia and there's
like people at restaurants and they're
strapped they got their guns and stuff
and so you think about the two different
americas the people in new york would
probably
scream and freak out oh they would freak
out yeah they would freak out like
there's that that photo of a guy who's
got to be you're not allowed to like
carry guns in new york you're not
allowed to have concealed you're not
allowed to carry it openly
unless you're an agent of the state
right
yeah
the cops are allowed to when i'm when
i'm in uh you know people have asked me
like if i was in west virginia i saw a
guy walking around with like a bunch of
guns and like an ar-15 and like a
shotgun would you like ron what would
you do and i'd be like i probably
wouldn't think anything at all
i i wouldn't
i'm like that guy's got guns
now if he had like
carrying a ton of guns
i would especially not worry you know
why he's not going to be able to move
around
so like you see someone with a gun i'm
like i see people driving cars all the
time i never expect a car to veer off
the road and slam into me yeah don't
expect the person to pull out a gun and
shoot at me i always expect the car to
veer off the road
and get me that's new york i guess right
no i mean even just driving up i've only
had my license for like literally a year
uh
but yeah when i drive around i think
like it would be so easy to kill me
right now isn't that crazy people just
go i used to when i was a kid i'd be
like what if everyone in the world
wanted to all of a sudden just wanted to
kill me how long could i survive
like five yeah yeah there's no way no
we're so vulnerable we're incredibly
vulnerable creatures
that's why we need exo suits like
gundams
and that's what we should do all of the
profits from tim cast media will be
funneled into an r d project for
building the first mobile suit gundam
and then when the anti-photoshop to my
house i'll be like
fly off into space what it really means
is that we have to accept risk as a
component of existence we need to be
relatively fearless in the face of
that we need to know that we're going to
die that we can't just be protected all
of the time we need to accept that we
need to revel in it and we need to step
out our front doors
willingly and accept all of that you
know except that we're not safe and that
it's fine it's fine to not be safe it's
good to take risks if we don't take
risks that we have no reward this is the
issue is that of course we know that of
course the people watching know this but
the cult doesn't care no like they want
to win they want to crush you it's fun
look at what look at what they want they
want to go to school for they want to
have secondary and whatever education
for free if they've paid for it they
want it to
they want that money back or they want
to not have to pay for it they want rent
to be fully covered they want the
government to pay out
money
endlessly if you don't have a job or if
you just don't want to get a job or
whatever they want to require businesses
to pay certain wages
um you know higher than the current
minimum wage they want to do all of
these things in order to
control society in order to regulate how
everybody is to live their lives and
there's no room to i mean where are the
artists going to come from where the
entrepreneur is going to come from where
the explorer is going to come from the
left has completely forgotten that
in our hearts we are a race fix
the left is a picasso painting
and the right is like an ikea
instruction
pamphlet if what you're saying is we
have no conservative culture you are
correct yeah you know what i mean that
is an issue
the right is like
very straightforward and here's what we
believe here's why we believe it here's
what we want here's what we're going to
do and then they kind of just like it's
not used it's it's tossed to the side
and then someone tries jamming the thing
together without actually crappy
materials and yes and the tool is a
picasso painting where you're like i
think that's a person your policies are
a mishmash that come together and it's
not a readable document so i love the
easiest example to understand why a lot
of a lot of uh leftist policies make no
sense uh we'll use the green new deal
when they started talking about a green
new deal i was like ooh
oh i like how this sounds what are you
saying like we'll allocate government
funding from like war
r d into like renewable energies maybe
oh would oh what if they start doing
infrastructure projects to
reduce our our dependence on foreign
foreign energy and things like that and
create maybe fusion ignition a green new
deal sounds pretty good a major jobs
project that works us towards energy
independence that'll make us more
that'll improve the economy and then aoc
comes out and goes free collagen free
healthcare and and if you're if you're a
different if you're not white we'll give
it to you first and i'm like
that that's not a green one
has anyone proposed a green new deal
like you just said no why
okay well well to be fair probably
but aoc's green new deal was like and
you'll get free college and people who
aren't white will get use reparations or
something like that i don't think she
actually said reparations but it was
like
identitarian free college then then then
you had on a website saying like we need
to stop air travel and farting cows and
i'm i'm not exaggerating literally said
farting cows and i'm like dude i made a
video where i was like a green new deal
sounds great
because we've been nation building in
other countries for so long we talked
about it here we were like what if we
did nation building in our own country
that would be actually kind of a green
new deal right instead what we get from
the progressives is this mishmash of
social justice trash that has nothing to
do with the environment but we also
don't
know go ahead we don't get enough from
like like we said there hasn't been a
counter proposal that oh the right
obvious enough the republicans are
trashed exactly
the republicans are like the democrats
go we would like to infringe upon your
right to keep and bear arms and the
republicans just are like
no
don't don't
and then one by one more and more laws
come in and then you'll get these
republicans who are like
uh i i don't think it's a good bill and
we shouldn't we shouldn't pass a law
restricting infringing the rights to
keep and bear arms and then their aid
will lead them and go the new york times
just called you a nazi i i always wanted
to ban guns i was i was the first one
who wanted to do it and so
step by step our rights are being eroded
it's particularly second amendment
and republicans don't come out and say i
would like to repeal all the nfa like
where is the republican literally
marjorie taylor green lauren robert
lauren borbert can you please propose
repealing the nfa why won't even lauren
bober do that
she's like
like the prostate gun republican maybe
she has maybe i'm wrong but i certainly
think that you can come out be like nfa
i think a lot of this comes down to
there not being any conservative culture
i mean these values that you're talking
about um you know and i think freedom of
speech is actually
well under attack as well but it's
being attacked more from the corporate
side
fully backed by the federal government
but we don't have a conservative culture
movement that shows these values that
gives a voice to these concerns
in a way that uh shows up every day on
people's
you know tick tock streams or
tv shows or movies or in books or
anywhere you know we just don't see it i
was um listening to
jack fasobic has a new podcast and he
was talking about his children's book
which is like an anti-communist book for
kids
we're at the point where we need
anti-communist books for kids
that's right
what is this you know and i think a lot
of this has to do with the failure of
the conservative movement to provide
entertainment options or anything that
people want to consume
i think people are correct i mean i'm
personally allergic to identifying left
or right in the first place i just i
can't make myself do it so and i think
that that's quite common with the youth
so you know i agree with what you're
saying but at the same time i feel like
the labels are just dead
well no no let's be real i mean
all the forms are known left and right
are
they used to mean they sort of meant
something it was the french the french
from french parliament but i mean like
that on the left the people said on that
it's completely meaningless today
they're they're revolutionary yeah the
right were reactionaries opposing they
were they they didn't want a revolution
uh
it's it's it's tribal it's tribal
signifies this point
if you are in favor of the democratic
establishment you are typically the left
if you are an opposition to the
establishment politics which includes
neocons republicans never trumpers then
you are on the right whether you believe
in right-wing politics or not it's
meaningless so basically i can be like
i'm pro-choice i would like universal
health care and they're like tim's right
wing and i'm like tell me which
politician i would vote for in the
republican party if that's the case
because i was like chelsea gabbard and
andre yang seem all right and then
you know i have my criticisms of them as
well
i i would vote for rand paul because he
seems to be like the only principal well
i'm sorry that's not fair thomas master
is pretty awesome too but there's like
very few actually principled people in
in government at all and then even when
i do look at people like ted cruz or
holly i'm like i just don't agree
outside of the liberty stuff so
politically homeless i guess but it
doesn't matter
if you believe in freedom
that's the right because you you'll see
this freedom is political and then
absolutely what was the new york times
headline
i don't know which one were they were
saying like the the right-wing freedom
chanting
remember freedom champions they were in
cuba they were chanting right right
right
yeah and then the white house was like
they just they just want more vaccines
that's that's what they're looking for
where is anybody on the actual left to
say mandating vaccines is wrong now
there have been some black lives matter
protesters saying vaccine mandates are
wrong legit weren't there some outside
the cdc in atlanta today i don't know i
don't know
if there were black lives matter though
oh were they not yeah i don't know but
but they it was a bunch of young black
people who were protesting interesting
nicki minaj was correct fauci's lying
so what ends up happening is you do have
your overarching you know um
conservative ink and then you have
establishment left which includes
the the foe progressives these big
youtube channels and streamers who claim
to be on the left but then like buy
themselves extravagant houses or try to
union bust in their own companies so
left and right
you know
when someone says something something
because i'm on the right jack said a
couple times last night i didn't say
anything about it but when they do that
i'm
here's my label they've lost they've
fallen in the swamp and they sunk and
they die you cannot label yourself and
get through this this is not a
political all right cult or not cult
we'll do that cult or not and then
you've got to define the cult too yeah
so like do you challenge um narratives
who who was it was it mark twain that if
you find yourself in the majority you
should you know that's aurelius marcus
aurelius yeah that's an old old one you
should question what you're thinking if
you find yourself in line with them so
uh
yeah there are some things that i'm like
i believe this and i will stand by it
and uh that means i'm willing to
criticize high profile individuals who
might you know uh be friends of mine or
might have you know certain access that
would that would i would benefit from
but i'm not gonna i'm not going to jim
brewer best example when he canceled his
shows over the vaccine mandate he was
like i'm not going to be beholden to the
system of money you know if to do
something i don't believe in and i'm
like right on jim
dude red red dude well this is why
language matters so much and like you
know huxley and orwell were obsessed
with it and it's just like we have to be
specific in the language because
obviously conservativism is a great
principle liberty liberalism should be a
great print like but those words i don't
want that no
i know they don't mean anything but i'm
just saying using them
is so limiting and the in the language
is being hijacked that's what's that's
what's happening so we have to be
specific in the language that we're
using well yeah i mean it's interesting
too that even in our cultural
conversations we are
adhering to
a two-party system
well i mean we i i think
the mises caucus guys are legit and
we've had dave smith here many many
times because they're they're like the
best we've got at this point and like
they're pro-life i i don't agree with
them a lot of things but i agree with
them enough at least we can identify a
lot of the problems and i'm like if the
republicans won't even identify the
problems and the establishment democrats
are reveling in the problems i'll take
the the mesococcus guys who are at least
pointing to it that's bad here's our
plan i don't know if your plan's going
to work but at least you're going to put
the
it's like the republicans and democrats
are ignoring the fire or the democrats
are lighting the fire and the
libertarians like we got a plan to put
it out and i'm like i don't care what
your plan is do it dude that's why we
need to do things outside of politics
politics is
should really not be the the top thing
that we're dealing with i think politics
is irrelevant building technology you
know we should be making art why are we
not out there making more art yes
exactly
i miss making art it's what you do that
all the time you're doing it right now
you were just saying this about
conservatives though they're not
offering actually you both kind of made
a similar point you said where's the
conservative
rebuttal or offer after the democrats do
something and you said conservatives
aren't building they're not making art
and culture to inspire or whatever right
that's it like the left has i'll tell
you and art also doesn't need to be
about any of those things i mean your
values come through in the art that you
create because you are a
principled individual who believes in
things and that expresses with your
heart that's a lot of what we're trying
to do with the new shows we're launching
it's not to make political content to
convince anybody of any ideas but to
tell stories that will inspire and our
values are conveyed throughout i want to
help teach people how to cook yeah i
actually want to learn how to cook while
i'm at it wait you're really doing a
cooking show
a couple days ago
another one went up yesterday i said you
want to avoid the sodium chloride and
use salt i meant sodium benzoate
sodium is salt thank you youtube
so check it out i love to cook me too i
do think join my cooking show
i do think that there's a possibility of
a polar shift in in in culture
that prevents a total collapse
i still think it's most likely there is
a collapse but what i'm getting at is
when it comes to the creation of culture
the establishment is failing miserably
and it's getting worse and worse since
gamergate and comics gate and all this
stuff it has continually just been
rather bad in a lot of ways now some
stuff's shined through and been okay a
lot of stuff has been bad like the new
uh the craft remake which was actually
like a sequel and it made literally no
sense and it was just jamming in a bunch
of woke plot points that i'm very
confused by and i'm like i don't
understand like they cast a spell to
turn a guy gay a lot of that stuff is
just unwatchable it's like watching
those christian productions we said this
before like flicks yeah pure flicks like
i don't know i don't know what a rag on
fearless i've been see i haven't seen it
but it's like those low grade like
poorly produced conservabro like right
christian content that we used to make
fun
fun of like i think i think even sheamus
mentioned bible man and stuff yes and
it's like not inspiring kids don't kids
want to watch x-men and now now now you
know what i love about x-men is the the
the allusions to civil rights right
right but now the left is latching on to
that and making x-men they're trying to
make it like woke the comics have
definitely gotten woke yeah they're
doing like all marvel wilkie stuff on
disney and it's
it's it's sales are going down i really
want a star trek
history shows didn't was it wasn't
wasn't discovery woke i didn't watch it
yeah either no i just watched ds9 again
instead that was right yeah because
something was special about that era in
star trek yes so it was like what 93
that launched
uh 89 the next generation i think next
generation was it
88 yeah and then ds9 was like i think
93. yeah i think so and then it went
into like the late 90s and then they did
enterprise and it was just enterprise
was garbage yeah i had so much promise
too the great story scott bakula one of
my favorites i didn't want a sequel we
just had the dominion war come on yeah
and now we get these weird hokey pseudo
sequels i'll tell you picard was pretty
good i like picard and you can do
the social justice stuff right
but the problem is look at the social
justice stuff that they did on ds9 when
benjamin cisco went back in time and was
uh
[Laughter]
yeah anyway but what happened they did
they went back in time uh san francisco
and he was a sci-fi writer and so he
wrote a um
he wrote a story about a black space
captain in the future and the uh
publishers of the magazine said no we
can't run this with a black space
captain and they ended up deciding to
run it but it was a dream that it was a
black space captain
which you know there were so many layers
in there and that character
in the timeline ended up um in a mental
institution scribbling his stories on
the wall i mean it actually it was
transcendent it like transcended
it was just perfect space nine was
fantastic avery brooks was we got killer
we got recommended the episode i think
it's called in the pale moonlight and
it's where cisco stages
uh uh
uh what
i'm forgetting but basically he stages a
conflict
to force the romulans to enter the war
on the side of the federation yeah and
it's like
conspiracy evil stuff it's it's that
show was fantastic it was fantastic and
he was such a complicated captain i look
back at
i i thought about this i'm like pick
hard
was good and for let me just stress too
if you're not a trekkie don't worry like
i want to keep this like you know at the
surface level
the new show that came out picard we're
doing a season i'm like it's a good show
but it was not profound yeah it was it
was not profound not thought-provoking
not inspiring it didn't inspire me to do
anything it was like it's really fun to
see riker and picard hanging out
but when you watch the original star
trek
like
well that but mostly i think that i like
the next generation better when you
watch the next generation it deals with
the philosophical consequences of
technological advancement and other
societies advancement stargate does that
really really well as well told me to
watch that i still have to watch that
it's it's not the same but it's similar
and it's like we had these shows in the
90s that were like
here's a civilization that dealt with
that that you know instead of
inventing electricity they discovered
you know plasma or something and then
it's like how did how did they develop
what are their ideas
there's that really really really great
moment where data asks picard about
terrorism and he says
something troubles me about you know
these people and their conduct and it's
you know we say terrorism is bad
yet it seems their strategies are
effective and often throughout history
we have seen these actions actually
bring about political change and picard
is like humans have been struggling with
these questions for generations and i do
not subscribe to the belief that
political power is derived from the
barrel of a gun and i'm like that was
like who are these writers who are just
like thought provoking philosophers
you know you know i was thinking of
when you hear about quotes from famous
people like ben franklin it's because
only so many of his words could actually
be translated through history could
actually be handed down because he would
write books he would write things but of
all of the words the man said probably
.001 percent of his ideas have made it
throughout history
today
you have these writers of these shows
building culture and giving these
profound ideas on like the make of a man
when when when data is on when there's
trial determined whether it's a sentient
independent life form that's a great the
people who wrote that are brilliant
philosophers
and we're not going to take their names
and put the quotes down we're going to
put picard
data you know i think about the value
that tv and radio has given us as a
species and it's so great because it's
our ability to transmit information and
and like you said to pass the knowledge
down it's also created this danger where
you see hitler using the mass media to
brainwash the people and like how the
media today is kind of brainwashing so
but i think that the value outweighs
the danger so greatly so i imagine that
that's a very very good sign for our
species
do you think it's a coincidence that the
best memes came out of that
time of star trek
like all the memes that yeah the
internet are like yeah from that period
it's not surprising yeah you know what
you mentioned the 90s and i think the
90s to a certain extent were our reward
for
a difficult century
uh there was so much prosperity i
remember there just being
um i was a kid basically i mean i was
like in my
late teens and in my 20s and there was
just money everywhere i remember this i
was like hanging out with a bunch of
visual artists everyone was getting paid
to do something ridiculous and instead
was blowing it all on
the dinner and strippers and stuff we
had a great time uh but yeah that was
like the reward it was a cultural reward
there was art everywhere there was
amazing music came out of that era
we had an awful lot of equality we had
an awful lot of um
equality between the sexes women could
do whatever they wanted
the internet merged and then the dot-com
just went too far well i think i think a
lot of it too was um you know september
11th we had like a massive terrorist
attack it was shortly thereafter and
that kind of
that made everything crazy it was the
cold war dividend cold war ended and all
of a sudden we were like what do we do
with all this money and all these
resources and all these plans and all
these troops
we made a lot of art in the 90s there
was really good visual art came out but
then
china started to emerge as a greater
power
and then you had a bunch of problems
here in the u.s like the appeal of
glass-steagall and then the economic
crisis and now china's getting more and
more power
and now perhaps one of the biggest
issues is that we as a nation have no
ability to stop china from taking over
as the global superpower and global
economic power and it's just like the us
at this point is has become too feeble
to fight back as a nation yeah but not
as people we do oh go ahead
i think with crypto and and local
governance we can do it but no no yeah
that that's that's great we'll have
small pockets of independent
freedom-loving people who are tending to
their chickens which is fine but china
will be
dominating the culture of the planet
like the u.s did for so long
then they'll start putting out their
ideas of why freedom is bad and it's
already happening we're already starting
to adopt more of the chinese communist
style
governance and political control oh i
just saw a story that the chinese are
going to start doing social credit on
corporations now yes that's correct i
saw that too that's wild welcome to the
decision
they're also regulating content a lot
more now too that's a whole big thing
yeah they banned kids from playing video
games yeah yeah hour and night or
something three hours a week
but even though they banned bitcoin
mining in china it's not going to stop
the people of china from rapidly
adopting it i mean the like you can't
just assume that there's you know
monoculture in terms of the the thought
process of the of the citizens of china
crypto is still gonna dominate that
makes sense that you know the people are
not homogeneous in terms of their
perspective but
they are showing themselves to be
relatively squashable hong kong is not
hong kong anymore um you know there's a
genocide going on and pelosi i think
from that same interview that you pulled
up earlier
she was saying that yes china is
committing genocide against the uyghurs
but it's more important that we team up
with them about climate change
we're idiots like for letting this kind
of thing happen china also though had a
long period of time while
uh the west was engaging in the age of
exploration and all of that where they
were basically just isolationists
um
the u.s i think should have a lot more
ability to control its own destiny in
terms of energy independence in terms of
manufacturing independence
one thing trump did was he tried to get
more pharmaceutical production in the
u.s
localized in the u.s which i think
obviously we should be doing
why are we
you know for for
decades we let
so many asian countries basically be the
factories of the us and the factories of
u.s
corporations and u.s commerce and
there's no reason to keep doing that we
got gutted i mean except that americans
probably don't want to work any of these
jobs what with the free money being
but well
it's going to be a cold splash of water
in the face when americans who do these
tr like these these fake jobs like
like i tell that story when i first went
to vice and saw how much people were
getting paid and what they did for a
living i was like wow
if working class people in this country
could see inside new york media they
would there would be a revolution
overnight
could you imagine working 15 an hour
doing doing labor only to discover that
someone's getting paid 50 an hour to
like scour the internet for pictures of
a celebrity
and then they don't show up half the
time right they don't show up and they
don't got to go to work
i'm not kidding yeah the vice office
would be like empty half the time and
i'd be like oh where is you know
someone's on the bed no home
they'll just still write something i
guess i can only imagine the
conversations they have like the board
of directors cnn like when they're
behind the scenes at msnbc if if we had
access to that we we got to listen in on
that
yeah i think there would be a revolution
overnight the issue i'm bringing up is
that there are people who work hard
every single day and they come home with
calloused hands sweat pouring you know
drenched in sweat and they sit down in
their back hurts and they go to the
doctor and the doctor is like jim you
got a slip disk
and he's like
getting paid you know 40 grand a year
doing the stuff and it's like he's his
body is is in pain then there are guys
who it's like they finally got that
promotion they're working really really
hard and they they're older and then
there's a 20 year old getting paid
double their salary in new york to
complain about you for voting for donald
trump and they say you're a [ __ ] you're
a dumb ass you're so stupid and that
guy's breaking his back to build the
infrastructure in this company every one
of these construction guys who's out
there
and to like bring your stuff and then
they say you're a maggot and a plague
rat and they get double the money you
make
i i find it still so shocking because it
was it's what like
the country's basically half and half at
this point was like what 74 million
people voted for trump
uh the other half kind of voted for the
other guy yeah voted against trump right
voted against trump that's only what
they did but then also the thing with
the uh i think there's been a number of
polls coming out recently showing that
it's like 51 of americans are in favor
of vaccine mandates and 49 or not i know
that that's one poll i saw so it's def
it's definitely like half and half and
one half of the country is telling the
other half of the country that they're
garbage and that that half of the
country they don't know the ones doing
all of the work so i want to talk i want
to talk to you about uh cancel culture
and how it affects media companies
notably
that uh one of the sponsors for the
post-millennial where you are the
editor-in-chief yes that's right surf
shark
which is a vpn i believe right
they got a somewhat some antifa guy
tweeted at them that andy know was all
these stupid things right they lie about
and surf shark immediately was like
oh no shocked emoji we're so sorry we'll
immediately terminate our relationship
with them that's right so i i called him
out immediately i'm like dude and it was
all lies against andy it was none of it
was true if a but here here's here's the
point i made this is really really
important
surf shark responded to me they said hi
tim cast we're not supporting or
dismissing anyone our core goal is
protecting people's digital privacy and
security and we just don't want to be
involved in someone else's conflicts or
ideological disagreements which is a lie
surf shark you're liars you're bad
people
because when antifa tweets at you and
then you say you got it buddy we'll
sever ties with a business over your
ideology you're doing exactly that and
now that you're getting backlash for it
you have the nerve to come out and be
like we're not doing we're not we just
don't want to be involved
no
serve shark violated the privacy of the
post-millennial and andy now by publicly
tweeting they would terminate a business
arrangement over accusations made online
if they're willing to sacrifice or
violate the privacy look if they wanted
us ever they could have privately called
up and said guys we're not fans of this
conflict so we're not going to publicly
call you out on anything but we don't
want to work with you anymore that would
be private instead they publicly said
yeah look at those guys they're bad guys
we're not going to work with them
so
that's me calling them out but i'm
curious because i still saw ads on the
post millennial and uh i was wondering
if you had some more insight into this
uh spineless company selling out their
values out of fear from antifa
yeah it was actually pretty interesting
and shocking so it was basically
you know one tweet at this company um
saying that andy is a violent person
which i don't know if you guys have ever
met andy but he's like the furthest from
a violent person
uh that i've
almost ever met um
and then they said that they weren't
doing they they terminated our
relationship with them but they said
that or they actually did
they're not working with us anymore
because i still saw like like a week
later there were still ads for it yeah
it was lag oh
[Laughter]
so this this company
actually terminated a business
arrangement because some random
antivirus oh he deleted his tweets by
the way yeah he tweeted lies yeah then
they went no problem he took it down um
but then also
uh
oh yeah
yeah the ads came down a couple days
late we were busy apparently i'm hearing
but they wanted them removed but yeah so
we took the ads down
and you know they basically
gave legitimacy to these violent
extremists who wanted to
silence the media and silence the press
but going but so and they actually you
know they replied to customers too and
we have screenshots of this as well
because andy reached out on twitter and
was like hey if you hear from them
um and we have screenshots they they
told customers that andy was you know
violent and we weren't going to be
working with they weren't going to be
working with us anymore because of ant
there were a lot of people on the right
who said they've worked with surf shark
mm-hmm yeah i mean i i think that
they're i think this is a horrible thing
to do i think it's a horrible coming i
mean that shows that they don't actually
care right they're only responding to pr
issues yeah wow and it's really just
this one person said this thing
oh yeah no it's all nonsense i mean so
where do you where do you guys see the
sort of oh i'm only doing business with
a certain type
of political ideology going like do you
think that it's gonna move into like a
polarized corporate system it's going to
be
i mentioned this before like parallel
economies but i think people need to
boycott
and tell all their friends and family to
boycott
and the way i see it is if a company is
willing to
defame someone
privately and publicly
then
whatever it costs them in pr to run
those ads it should cost them 100 times
from the power of the people to say
you're bad and we reject this and then
going out and telling everybody because
i'll tell you this
people don't rem you know there's this
old saying i can't remember exactly but
it's like this advice you'll get and
media like a negative experience is 10
times worse you know or is like a
thousand times worse than a positive one
a positive experience is expected a
negative experience is infuriating so if
someone goes into your restaurant and
they order a cheesecake and it's a
delicious cheesecake they'll be like wow
that's so good well of course it should
be they probably won't give you a good
review they won't share your your
restaurant don't tell their friends
about it but if you have a cheesecake
and it like is gross they'll tell
everyone they know
so if these companies want to play this
game where they're willing to step up
stand up and shove themselves into an
ideological conflict and i'll mention
this too andy is the editor at large
he's theater at large yeah so to sever
their business arrangement over one
employee right and to violate the
privacy one editor we have a lot of
editors too
yeah i mean and we're keeping our legal
options open because this was clearly
defamation
yeah
defamation and libel
for every instance of it is in another
instance of libel for every person that
they contact yeah like every time they
say it every person they told
lies about andy and by saying that
they're yeah and by saying that they're
not getting involved they are very
clearly getting involved on the side of
this guy who you know just has it in for
andy because andy exposes antifa all
over the place and is very honest about
it and works hard at that we got to get
the post-millennial monetized with uh
minds
bill's like i'm not joking i'll make a
business move yeah let's do it follow up
yeah actually you told me the other day
you were like hey yeah yeah you got to
figure that out so i changed my password
because of course i couldn't find
anything and i found that somebody had
given me tokens all right that's money
so that was fun in the bank
you know there was a period where i said
i was like
a few years ago i'm like oh hulu did
something woke i'm not gonna boycott
because they said something dumb i'll
come you know i'll tell them it's dumb
i'm i'm well past that point i'm like
if a company comes out
and
does something like this which is
substantially worse than just posting
stupid you know
nonsense if they actively defame people
and enter the conflict i say go nuclear
share it with your friends share my
tweets with everybody tell everyone you
know anybody who has the service no
we're not going to work with you we're
not going to buy the same thing for
amazon
what what did when amazon bans people
yes all the time no i know but are you
are you boycotting amazon
uh that's a tough one half
half but you're right it's a good point
i actually started there were some
things that i was ordering on amazon and
i actually started ordering them from
the company specifically i'm not going
to say it because what if they say they
hate me and then i can't order their
stuff anymore but there's a it's
interesting what you were saying about
the parallel
economies because we switched you know
we switched mostly from using youtube
for our podcast and stuff at
post-millennial and now we're using
rumble for everything
and it's you know just fine and we like
them quite a bit
it's a lot you know
this is what we were talking about
culture and like in terms of creating
more culture
what is going to happen are there going
to be fully parallel economies with
different services based on ideological
perspectives yes and if so
you know where's the conservative amazon
part of it too is that the uh the
non-left-wing side of things doesn't
always do as great a job
you know what you know the issue they
don't have all the graphic designers
they don't have all the creatives you
know so what's going to happen with that
it is changing it's yeah it's definitely
changing and i think yes where's the
conservative to launch an amazon
marketplace i would i would buy from
them didn't mike lindell try doing
something i feel like that's again is
you're going too far it's like where's
the apolitical
place launching yeah the alternative you
know because it's like when you're here
where's the conservative alter it's not
oh it's like you don't just go to the
other side you know it has to be the one
that is there for everybody what what
i'm saying is
where the conservative side is the side
that allows you to sell karl marx and
hitler the left side is the side that
allows you to only sell karl marx and
that used to be the last you could you
could say you could say conservative or
maybe it's an apolitical free speech
supporting that's right wing bro
you can but you're falling into the trap
no no no free religion are on the right
way no no that stuff's beyond political
parties it used to be it's still not
detailed you
joe rogan is called alt-right bill maher
is called all but it's not joe rogan is
called far right and the dudes literally
in favor of ubi doesn't mean it's real
dumb people are using those terms
left and right don't mean anything and
never really did other than are you in
favor of the revolution or opposed to it
so yes if you oppose the left's woke
revolution you are the right republican
republican democrat don't mean anything
it's just a thing you tick it's no
different
republican and democrat refer to the
parties you don't expect your right wing
you do not accept that you're right i
have repeatedly said in terms of the
culture war i would be considered on the
right you would be considered but that
doesn't mean that that's what you are
well let me finish michael malus has
described this as the new right new
right personalities and his position is
ask someone this question i'll ask you
do you believe that some people are
better than others of course not
you don't think so that's well
that's the left position
the right the new right position is okay
well i sort of miss interpreting it
depends on what you mean by better
better better
are
is one human life more valuable than
another exactly so that's how i
interpreted michael are some people
michael's more ethical than others yes
what michael said is the left will
opine and and and justify
and the right will simply say yes
so here's here here's the issue
in terms of
the political compass my political
ideology leans left in terms of
cooperative you know i know right
libertarians don't like the idea but
cooperative meaning non
non-transactional more like i i'll help
you if you help me it doesn't really
scale up all that well so mostly i defer
to positions of liberty
however in the culture war i believe in
free speech i believe in religious
freedoms i believe in bodily autonomy
those things do not exist in any facet
on the left okay so maybe that's too
absolute maybe there's some people on
the left who are calling this out but
look at aoc going to the met gala with
her attacks the rich dress where a guy
carries it for her while wearing a mask
she is not that that's that's that's the
hero of the progressive left then you
look at the social the libertarian
socialist youtubers and streamers who
are celebrating rule by decree
if you when you come out and and you're
speaking colloquially in modern culture
the the free speech freedom of
association the right to read any book
you want is considered right-wing
yeah i don't disagree but that again
it's sort of adopting their paradigm
to to accept that right i suggest we do
instead
just erase those words from your lips
right and left and say
i'm happy to say liberty liberty is fine
and if people are going to associate
that with the right that's their
decision but you know liberty's not
going to get taken away and from the
language
part of the problem i think is that we
need to be able to communicate with one
another and so we need to share words
and those words need to have common
definitions do you not think that
liberty is a more effective word than
conservative or liber i mean i don't
want to say libertarian because
libertarian i know a political party but
liberty i think i i don't think is
co-opted
so you would say
you are i'm not def i'm not gonna i'm
not making the new term i don't know
but
i mean i've heard the the concept of
liberty minded i think
is cool you know there's there's
different words that can achieve it
without having that association i think
the what draws me that's my left concept
of you know yeah
yeah but we can't define ourselves in a
neg as a negative right right why do you
need to define yourself pro freedom i
mean come on who like
you're right that that will be
associated with the right but that is
actually
dude the gadsden flag
has one simple meaning
liberty leave me alone
yet
they they the the the antifa people have
a flag of the snake of the the communist
fist killing the snake squeezing it out
when when
if you go so i have friends
who are
the left
they will tell you outright they are in
favor of the state taking away your
freedoms so we can say freedom they'll
still say in the media in every
newspaper right wing
yeah that's
that's fine let them do that
the interesting thing i suppose is that
like on my wikipedia for instance says
i'm both left and right and they're like
i don't know
it's like his anti-corporate politics
are fairly left-wing and it's like bro
left and right don't mean anything other
than tribal signifiers at this point
like uh i think left and right could
probably broken down very very simply do
you question the narrative or do you
blindly follow it if you blind you
follow it that's what we consider left
if you challenge it that's what's
considered right wing so even if your
positions are like pro-choice
tax the rich universal healthcare ubi
and you challenge official narrative
they'll call you right wing i just think
there's a lot of people on the left that
don't want that to be the case the
freedom you know at the freedom sect of
the left they don't want that so that's
what's the freedom sect to the left
there is you know it's there the
the
um anarcho communist the libertarian
socialist i know you know
where they're when the libertarian
socialists are following prominent
individuals who celebrate rule by decree
and the unarco communists are fire
bombing small businesses i'm not they
are just lying about what they represent
i don't know
i don't know i don't i don't want to
give up hope that there is you know a
group of people
oh you know on on that end of the
spectrum that that do care about values
that that matter when gamergate happened
a lot of these people started posting
their political compass tests and they
were all left libertarian
now they're all like center center right
that happened to me i used to i
been taking those those little you know
cosmo testers of
political affiliation and it used to be
like all over here and now it's over
here but it's the same stuff like i'm
i'm voicing the same opinions they're
changing the algorithms yeah to make you
think that you're in some kind of club
or labeled some certain way to divide
you like don't play the game don't say
left and right don't put people in camps
and say they're conservative and this
because then they're going to use that
just to destroy the cults yeah they'll
destroy each little cult the
conservative cult the liberal cult the
left cult the right they will target
that sect of things that we've created
inadvertently we want to let ourselves
lazily do it so don't do it there's
there's
people want to be affiliated with each
other people want to be part of groups
it's understandable that's our in our
genetics to survive yeah i mean where
there's one called gone too far
there's one institutional cult and
that's it um we're not a hive species
no we're like um new york city looks
kind of like a hive sometimes yeah but
we i don't think humans are necessarily
hive animals we're more powered animals
animals yeah and and to identify tim i'm
so sorry i didn't even understand what
you just said because i was in the
middle of that conversation with libby
what did you just say you said you
started pointing out like the
conservative cult in this cult there's
only one cult oh
yeah obviously there's like cults they
exist
but
independent voters and republicans are
challenging the narrative republican
voters expressed disdain for the
republican party democrat voters
overwhelmingly believe whatever they're
told by but micah brazil from the other
perspective rachel maddow fox news is
the narrative that no one is blind no
from the other perspective no you're not
it is on narrative
when when tucker carlson came out and
said sidney powell was wrong they lost
like three million viewers do you want
to do something i was on his show that
what that night and i lost so many
twitter followers that night because i
was on the show where he slammed sydney
powell
but they still retained millions of
viewers and still is the biggest show
because people on the right are not
they're individualists they're they're
they're not unified for the most part
though there are different groups within
the right that make it up i'll put it
this way the the
no i forgot the analogy i was going to
use anyway the point is
the the left as we know it
the ones that are pro-vaccine mandate
the ones that believe trump colluded
with russia the ones that never let that
go they refuse to believe the facts when
stories come out and say like biden did
this
mark milly
called china outside the chain of
command all of this is the story is
developing being confirmed now we have
the defense secretary saying i never
authorized that now we have the defense
secretary saying if trump gave a
military order it should not be going to
to mark milly we know for effectiveness
and what is the mainstream narrative he
was a hero who stopped a madman that is
the cult that they can tell you to your
face they've shuddered the three
branches of government they have
bypassed the standard process of
legislation and the the the priests of
this the so-called libertarian
socialists are celebrating the the
usurping of civilian authority the
usurping of the branches of our
government
they're in a cult now if republican
voters like if trump voters republican
voters and independents argue with each
other all day and night but agree on
certain principles of freedom clearly
not a cult because i can have an
argument with somebody about like jack
the other day about family and
responsibility and we're not unified but
we'll hang out we'll have more shows and
we'll debate these ideas
look at what the left does on their
shows you can't challenge them brian
stelter won't have on glenn greenwald to
question him in any capacity but tucker
carlson brings on antifa all the time
if one side is saying challenge the
narrative and question science because
that's what science is supposed to be
and we'll absolutely entertain our
rivals positions and the left says never
going to allow it there's no let me let
me tell you one more slides dude let me
yes there are well there are people who
are willing to
one person i might not want to talk
today but tomorrow i could be in a
different mood there are tyrants like
gavin newsom who are putting rules in
place and then breaking them and you're
saying well it's no no no sides i agree
that he's acting like a tyrant yes we're
we're planning on saying that if you're
acting like a tyrant you are a tyrant
yeah sure but that doesn't mean that
people are on two different sides like
that's falling into the trap of the left
and the right and they're going to think
it's necessary i'm trying to fix you
cannot fix it if you're gonna play the
fault okay but here's the thing that
happened you have the let's call them
democrats because that's actually a
political party and we can agree on the
definition of that right so you have the
democrats gavin newsom nancy pelosi joe
biden kamala harris all of these people
they assumed that
they decided that trump's presidency was
a sham presidency right they decided
that that was the case they acted as
though that was the case for four years
they acted outside of
um traditional the law the sure yeah
durham is filing an indictment against
the lawyer who fabricated it
yeah so they did they acted
judiciously they acted outside of
legislative means because they believed
that trump was a sham president and they
assumed that everyone else believed it
too like look at even when biden was
running for um president and after he
won and he started saying america is
back as though america wasn't here for
the past four years the whole time look
we got to go to super chats but i'll say
one more thing
joe biden has come out on numerous
occasions looking into the camera and
addressing two nations
that's
it initially he said we need we need
more lockdowns we're gonna need more
restrictions at a time when red states
either didn't have them or were ending
their lockdowns when joe biden said that
it was clear he wasn't talking to
republican states recently he said our
patients is wearing thin he's not
talking about blue states because we
have the data from the cdc already blue
states are overwhelmingly vexed around
70 to 80 percent he was talking to
louisiana but red states are under 50
percent that's who he was there's no red
and blue states there's states where
like there might be a republican
governor and there's a 63 of the people
are registered republican it doesn't
mean the state is red there's a lot of
people of a lot of different super chats
yeah we are and i'm going to tell you
this
we are not going to have these fake
semantic arguments ever again this is
the point of the conversation is the
cement yes that is what 1984 is about
the the issue is that when we can have
three we have a room with five people in
it and four people can say to you the
definition of the word rights and for no
reason other than to just make a fake
argument you get into semantics we're
never doing that again what do you think
about rights we had a conversation about
what rights were and no matter how many
times we tried in good faith to give you
a definition you rejected it because you
weren't interested in actually coming to
an understanding you were just trying to
argue people were telling me the rights
were derived from god i was pointing out
that i don't think that that's true and
when we tried to explain what that meant
because you're taking it to a theistics
place instead of understanding the
definition you refused so we don't do
that so just one one question on that so
art
you think that just for practical
purposes it is
worthwhile to just
use the labels even though they don't
really mean anything you think that it's
sort of a pragmatic thing to just
do it they mean something yeah it's not
black and white there's nuance to it
like if you break down what left and
right means on political compass i'm
clearly on the left economically and uh
libertarian if you if you're talking
about the overarching culture war
then the left is simply people who agree
with what the left tribe wants and the
right is simply what people agree people
who agree with what the right tribe
wants and if the right tribe includes
libertarians
and even left libertarians
and the left doesn't include those
people then there's a clear
understanding of what left and right
means there are very clearly states that
have an overwhelmingly red population we
call them red states they're very
they're states that are overwhelmingly
blue and you can track a whole bunch of
data points across them for instance
vaccination rates blue states except for
the ones that uh trump challenged the
five states that were being challenged
by republicans those are the only low
vaccination rate blue states
but
every state that voted for trump outside
of those states
have low vaccination rates
every state that voted for joe biden
outside of the anomaly has high
vaccination rates when joe biden comes
out and looks in the camera and says our
patience is wearing thin
it is statistical it is impossible to
believe that he is talking to the states
that are already vaccinated he's clearly
there's a delineation between what this
country is
and he is telling the other group we
are losing our patience who's we they've
done it on more than one occasion
they've repeatedly gone on cnn these
pundits and said we need to make it
miserable for them and people have
pointed this stuff out don lemon keeps
saying that he right don lemon on cnn
keeps saying that people who are not
vaccinated should be segregated from the
rest of society and that they're
bringing the rest of the country down
and now we have a landlord in florida
who's saying i'm going to evict people
who aren't vaccinated so
there's very clearly
what people need to understand is that
we're not talking about a simple one
negative one two completely isolated
numbers mirroring each other there's
overlap in committees of people who
believe certain things there's
conservatives that live in blue areas
but the area is still overwhelmingly
dominated by a certain culture there are
different sides and and and the idea
that like you know when bill maher said
a civil war can't happen because the
mason-dixon line would run through
nana's kitchen
do you think that the states would just
go
he's like no idea what he's talking
about anyway let's read super chats yes
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends and go to
timcast.com because we will have that
bonus segment coming up
all right
we got nicholas lip sets as i wonder if
those that didn't submit their vaccine
to the cdc are counted in the stats for
the vaccinated i didn't and don't have
my card anymore i also know a lot of
others that didn't
interesting
people have also mentioned that the
cards were too big for wallets and they
had lost them already
i think you were mentioning that too
right yeah in new york yeah
odra noel
zenetram says it's not the country
falling apart it's the centralization
forced upon by the fed this is a good
thing also enough of the china
fearmongering they're broke and saber
rattled with paper mache saber i think
that's wrong yeah i disagree with that a
lot of people have tried pushing that
narrative of like oh china is weak and
they're tiger they just want us to
believe that so that they can you know
smart
take over the world kevin burns says the
animated shorts on the cast castle are
great they call him eon
they they are absolutely wonderful and
if you haven't already go to
youtube.comcast
subscribe to the vlog new episodes every
day
all right let's see what is this
vet hazmat says tim you make my soul cry
paying absurd secondary market pricing
for hard-to-find bottles these shops are
price gougers and have these dusty
bottles sitting around for a reason they
harm the whiskey
they harm the whiskey calm
yes i am aware it is hard to find
certain bottles and i don't know what to
do so you go to a place and they're like
we charge a premium on and i'm like if
you want to get it i don't have time to
go drive around the country looking for
the stuff at you know better prices
mark oh
mark giudi secession is treason
encouraging it is inciting treason so
please stop being a traitor tim you are
better than millie so don't be a traitor
encouraging secession what that's a
that's quite a leap that whole that
whole thread there yeah absolutely
really sentences quite moves it's a
perspective yeah it's one effective yeah
it is a view
that a person has that's right he's
allowed
let's see well uh dernaven says fun fact
secession is in the new is in new
hampshire's constitution oh that's
interesting well there you go i need to
learn more
dee says my mom's doctor took the vax
but recommended she not get it due to
heart problems one of the leading causes
of death in the u.s is heart disease in
fact it is the leading cause i think 660
000 people per year die of heart disease
that's a lot yeah and it is mostly older
people but it scales down to younger
people so i think you know maybe we need
to protect people people's hearts from
the the unhealthy
yeah probably so we got to triage this
stuff we can't if someone comes into a
hospital and they're like you know
my heart hurts and someone else is
morbidly obese sorry more believers
person you get out that's what the left
has been saying right yeah they've been
the they've been saying that uh
their their version of personal
responsibility is that you are
responsible for the diseases you get the
call but nothing else all right
we'll say the cultists okay but you're
not responsible personally for anything
else you're not personally responsible
for the debts you incur or the jobs you
won't take or anything cultist is
actually a great word you just keep
using more there you go
let's see andrew star says ian's show
should be called getting baked with
cosmic garth
i like it
all right
seriously jk says imagine spearheading a
mass effort to actually show the culture
war to people who are not paying
attention then show them twitter for the
first time so they can see what is
actually going on minds would be blown
that's politics
a lot of people have no idea and i think
it's funny when you know people like
these high-profile comedians who are
like in politics
don't go online and they don't know how
twitter influences the world
and then you go on twitter and like some
random idiot tweets and then a media
company loses a sponsor because some
idiot lied on twitter
i had a lot of respect for nicki minaj's
uh yeah statement last night that she
came out with i thought it was good so i
i just real quick i looked up the
secession treason thing and secession in
itself i do not think is a form of
treason going to war with a country is a
form of treason which is basically what
happened in uh civil war yeah it could
be considered sedition but treason is
adhering to the enemy or providing them
aid in comfort
so if they're if new hampshire is like
yo we out they can say that seditious
but i don't think it's treason i don't
see it like telling another country that
we'll give them fair warning if we're
going to attack just on the side that
sounds like treason that's not so great
blackrock beacon says ian they do have
cult leaders many of them the cult is
more like a religious organization that
is preachers it's the blue church the
cathedral
that's one way to put it
let's see demma is that a
it's hard to read as an rn or an m
demoven says article 10 of the nh bill
of rights is the right of revolution we
have secession already there
so if you're not familiar with the free
state project you can check out their
website they're basically like you sign
a pledge saying we're going to move
there and just completely advocate for
freedom so there you go
crom mike says ian i understand that you
are resisting fear panic and trying to
be optimistic i would ask you though
when have they ever given up their power
who is there there is also not one
hitler to point to on purpose that way
you cannot aim your rage onto one person
you aim at a party george washington
gave up his power
that's what he's saying is
the left is a group of people
and many of them are in powerful
positions
and many of them are just cogs in the
machine blindly following and giving
their resources in power to empower
these people who then do things like
gavin newsom shut the president but he
says everybody we're shutting down your
businesses hollywood you're good to go
ladies small business you're shut down
me by the way i'll go to a restaurant
violating all the rules and not where
i'm asking i mean if you zoom out i
think all of us as americans are are
blindly giving money or base supporting
a system like this this total it's not
totalitarian but it's like a world
military this this whatever's taken over
the united states by us like kind of
passively enjoying the united states his
benefits were
supporting it i think trump voters yeah
it's been awesome for him on the basis
of him saying he was going to be getting
out of the middle east and then he
gained something like 11 million new
voters because he was actively getting
our troops out of the middle east and
setting forward for putting these deals
in place i think most americans don't
want these wars do want to get out don't
want the tyranny they want to have their
homestead they want to have their family
they want to be left alone and live
peacefully and not be engaging in global
conflict the problem is there is a cult
that is willing to elect joe biden a
warmonger
and re-empower the establishment to go
about blowing stuff up and there you go
but it's also been i mean it's been the
implementation of crisis politics for
the past
20 years and we have taken those crises
looked at them and said okay because of
this crisis we will give up our rights
right we gave up our rights with the
patriot act uh the formation of the
department of homeland security which
now seems to believe that domestic white
terror white white supremacy is the
biggest terrorist threat facing the
country uh we just have systematically
given up our rights ever since september
11th willingly
saying you know we're not going to hold
our representatives to account and we
still don't
i think why don't we the cult is global
um it's it's a
and to divide the americans up now is
not good because it is there is a cult
that put joe biden in power and it's not
american
it's some weird global organization dude
like i don't think the great reset is
real it's a global call
yeah that's true but i do think that
it's about time america dealt with
itself
but not by dividing ourselves maybe not
by dividing ourselves but you know i
think that we should be american
exceptionalists i think we should look
at our nation and say these are the
things we stand for they are right and
true and good and we're going to stand
for them no matter what i think i think
the issue is that ian hasn't experienced
what it means to go up against evil like
right so when you have what we call the
cult
and i will in good faith communicate
with a journalist and provide them hard
evidence that the claims made against me
are not true
and they purposefully omit that because
their real goal is destruction and pain
like you're like wow
that's evil and so you're like we
shouldn't divide ourselves bro you're
letting a fox in the hen house under the
presumption that well we're all animals
we can all live together it's like but
we watched the fox murder the hens don't
let it in the henhouse and you're like
we shouldn't divide ourselves we're all
creatures of god's green earth well
we're all american citizens we're not
foxes and hens
the point i'm making is that
you can look at aaron rupar
a guy who's so notorious for lying that
he has a word
yes he does people call it
when you take someone out of context on
purpose and lie about them he does it so
often and he works for a a major company
that's massively funded and he supports
people like joe biden who enriches his
family off corruption hillary clinton
who takes all of these emails and
deletes them and destroys them whose
staff smashed cell phones with hammers
now i'm not saying the republicans are
good they're bad people too
trump came in as a bull smashing in as
an insurgent candidate causing a lot of
problems on that for for the
establishment neocons who immediately
then joined the democrats the lincoln
project supposedly conservatives now
they're pro-choice because they have no
principles they are pro-establishment
when you go and see antifa throw an
explosive at an a 60-70 year old woman
when i watched in san jose a mob of
leftists with some with bernie shirts on
shove a 60 a couple of old people in
their 60s to the ground take their hats
off their head and set them on fire
you think you're going to unite with
these people you've not experienced it
what's your what's your other option i i
went to a group of trump supporters and
i said i'd like to talk and said no
problem sir would you like to join us
for dinner
daryl davis walked over to the
protesters at our event and said you
guys and they said nazi shame nazi and
he was like i what's happening and then
he posted he posted on facebook i've
never experienced this before that he
walked up to klansmen and they allowed
him to come and talk with him though and
those people are bad people but he was
able to find some good some light in the
darkness and pull that out of the
shadows that i understand but when you
are confronting this corrupt
mold this
destructive chaotic force that not even
daryl davis could break through it's the
system you have to change the system
it's a
and the cult is a derivative of the
system of the federal of the fractional
reserve of this weird the media media
yeah it's more than that it is a cult
it is not that the media one day the guy
who owns cn you know jeff zucker
president he didn't go to a meeting
where they're like we want to
indoctrinate everybody was like you got
it they eat their own refuse it is a
sewer jack dorsey used to be the the ceo
of the of the free speech wing of the
free speech party but then twitter
became this hive of scum and villainy
where people were making money off of
being [ __ ] and then jack ate all of
that refuse and then espoused it back
out and still does
they are being infected by their own
psych algorithmic psychosis
and now you have people in the streets
genuinely believing that black people
are being hunted down by the police and
murdered which is not true and they're
burning down small businesses and
killing people because of it there is a
problem in this country and there are
people who are standing up
criticizing the narrative and
questioning it and even challenging me
they'll say take me wrong about this tim
you're wrong about that every single day
but in that world i can't even get a
single leftist to show to talk to alex
jones
we want to have
yeah we we we booked one person and they
said i'm so excited to do this and then
canceled on us at the last minute i
reached out to a few more and they'll
say the same thing i will not do this
why because they're in a cult and if
they stand up and ever associate with
anyone on the other side like we would
like to they will be destroyed they know
it and they refuse that's why so many of
the anti-sjw youtubers from back in the
day during gamergate flipped and are now
leftists or at the very least bowed out
of the fight because they're more
worried about them their their their
ability to make money than to stand up
for their principles and they know the
encroachment of the catec destructive
force is seeping into more and more
institutions and they've bet we will
lose i don't care if we lose because
i'll get my van and go down by the river
but i'll be damned if i'm gonna sit here
and be like the dude who threw a brick
through the mom and pop bakery shop or
burned it down and killed a guy let's
unite with those people they're good
people well anyone you can have
compassion you know on a human level for
them but also not play their game and
call them out for you know which you do
quite frankly you it's not i'm like i
think that ian likes to play the
semantic game but he also does call out
things
when
you know it's obvious and like
so i you can do both at the same time
yeah i think we have to you have to you
have to stop the
the actions of violence but also
understand that those people can be
de-radicalized
daryl davis i don't think they want to
be de-radicalized well that's the thing
and like they have their i mean they
have everything they have all of culture
they have all of politics for the most
part why would you possibly daryl
doesn't deserve people daryl doesn't
can't look you can't force someone to
de-radicalize so daryl only engages with
people who are willing to talk to him
and they weren't and they were and they
weren't exactly so you can't you're not
gonna convince you're not gonna force
someone to change daryl deals with
people over years at a time listens to
them literally for months hating on him
and then eventually
they start asking questions about him
did you see the picture of the woman in
the gorilla mask throwing eggs at larry
elder yeah i thought that was actually
uh do you guys remember the gorilla
girls
so the gorilla girls were a
you know basically a leftist activist
group where they would all wear gorilla
masks to stage actions and i think that
that was actually
it looked to me like a gorilla girl mask
but also it was sort of amazing that
this person was unaware
seemingly unaware that they were wearing
they're zombies like a really that would
be so racist yeah they would just be so
racist to wear a gorilla mask and throw
eggs at a blackjack a black man you know
what the who the heck is there zombies
right you know
they're zombies
you know you were talking about them and
they were recently i think it was in
portland and they were
um attacking christians and throwing the
christians were having like a you know
some sort of prayer thing and they threw
all their sound equipment i was i was in
uh san bernardino
and
there were trump protesters and antifa
protesters
and i was just there filming and a bunch
of the people
on the right some of them knew i was a
few years ago
i walked over to the antifa people and
they were standing there holding signs
and i was like hey would you guys wanna
and as soon as i did a woman came up and
started going mic check my check mic
check
and then they all started repeating her
mic check mic check and she goes do not
speak do not speak to anyone to anyone
they're trying to trick you they're
trying to trick you
and then i was like oh that sounds
pretty tricky they do that all the time
and then i was like would any of you
guys and they completely ignore me would
not say anything
because it is a zombie horde it is a
cult there is no unifying with people
who
you can't even talk to
you if you can't even invite them to sit
down
so there are some people that i think of
as reasonable on the left that are
leftist that are like hate trump and all
stuff
they won't come on of all of the people
that's why i'm like my respect to vosh
people rag on them all the time but he
came here twice
and so there are a handful of people i
know who follow me they're on the left
and they refuse to come and have a
conversation with people on the right
dude i'm on the
show with you dude
i'm the other i'm the guy on the left
i'm here with you you're not on the left
ian i mean basically you're not i'm
pretty much a socialist leftist but just
because you can't unify with somebody
now you know it's okay to say
you know
okay yeah
at some point in the distant future
someone who will refuse to have a
conversation now maybe in 30 years
they'll be ready for a conversation but
someone like daryl davis is not going to
force someone who needs you know 20
years to you know be willing to come to
the table at the end of the day people
need to be willing to have the
conversation part of what's going on
though is it's not just about having a
conversation it's about there being
entirely divergent world views
so these you know cultists leftists
whatever the word is that we are coming
up with this evening
they don't have there's not a same world
view there's not a same perspective on
what america is on what society should
be about on what values should be it's
like we don't have the same
concept of reality at this point if you
like a great example would be watch joy
read
and then watch tucker carlson and you'd
be shocked to find that they are
actually in the same world
in the same country and you'd be shocked
to find that joy reads lying
half the time and tucker is opinionated
they're probably both represented by the
same talent agency for
right for gigs
tucker criticized simon schuster but
then he has his book through simon
schuster well that's why he was
criticizing simon schuster
like he was criticizing simon schuster
based on his experience
working with them
if we can look at all of the economic
numbers across the board i'm not saying
he was right about that by the way if we
can look at every economic number from
the loss of jobs job openings jobs being
filled unemployment increasing all of
these things and be like these are bad
indicators if we can see that projected
gdp growth is actually dropping down to
slightly above average at a time when
we're supposed to be this massive
recovery and we're getting more
lockdowns now the vaccine mandates are
causing businesses to decline there's a
massive labor shortage so people are
struggling to hire and then the
democrats go the economy is pretty good
yeah yeah they don't live in reality
dude no media's twisted twisting people
but it's coordinated from way beyond the
united states and you can't break them
out of it because cult techniques the
way you get someone out of a cult is you
remove them from the cult and don't let
them communicate with the cult until
they can snap out into reality but now
they have smartphones that assure them
no matter what happens they will always
be hooked into the matrix
how do you get them out of it
you can't i have i have family members
who have lost their minds i have friends
who have lost their minds people like
they're people i grew up with who are
going on twitter and making things up
about me there was one story my favorite
story was that at two a.m
i went to an activist's house in boston
and turned their tv on waking up
everyone in their house
and i'm like how dare you what and
people were commenting like whoa i can't
believe tim would do that and i'm like
that's insane when was i in boston
i don't know you how'd you get the
remote but they make these things up i
have i have friends that i used to skate
with every day that i grew up in chicago
that are going on twitter and lying
about me because they're in a cult and i
have actually messaged them like i've
known you for 15 years you know that's
not true about me here's more evidence
from my private files proving that story
was fake and they go i don't care
they're in a cult they do they actually
say that they don't care
they don't overtly say the words i don't
care
they just will put me on read and then
say something like
well i'm reading the news so and then
they if i give evidence so i have one
friend who was posting lies about me
based on a fake article and then i
showed him private
business records like bro i've known you
for decades like look at this right here
that story is not true
and then he went right back to twitter
and started posting the same lies and
and so i
mentioned him again i was like dude
if you don't care about the fact that i
can give you the records proving the
story's a lie
you're nicole
he would rather ignore the evidence and
maintain the lies to be part of the mob
that's burning the country down yeah i
like this this cult metaphor is a lot
easier to understand than left and right
for me because it they are kind of in a
cult where the cult leader is this this
media apparatus
we got to read some more super chats
because
we we didn't do enough
the raptors talent says are you planning
on hiring video games journalists i
would offer myself or not for my
complete lack of journalistic experience
perhaps
but uh we have a whole bunch of irons in
the fire right now and we need to first
launch the mystery show which we've been
working on for some time we've had way
to do graphics we're coding the website
to be able to handle the new new members
content right now timgest.com has
members content but it's all tim cast
irl in order to launch a new show with
members content we have to be able to
separate the different shows when you go
to the members area so it's going to be
like any one of these streaming services
with different shows and i think we have
like seven shows in production so i'm
trying to make sure we're not spreading
too thin and we're actually going to get
these shows cranked out
but we've actually been filming to
produce a lot of these the next step is
the website needs to be coded to handle
the multiple shows
we have one show that's basically ready
to go the mysteries show you're gonna
love it we have awesome art for it
already and great stories
and uh it'll be really really great
zappler says tim i completely agree with
you about creating new culture i'm
working on releasing a new novel about
vampire hunters called
or is it wilting blood that is both
entertaining while also promoting good
values early reactions are positive
really really cool cool name good to
hear
all right let's see we'll grab we'll try
and grab some of these uh
that person should look into the
critical theory uh that was embedded
into buffy the vampire slayer which is a
very real thing the creators of buffy
the vampire slayer were you know
thinking the tv show yes yes the
creators were you know embedded in that
narrative inside yeah i've watched that
whole thing twice
6.8 says tim you need a foia task force
to pry the info out of these a-holes
props man you're the new glenn beck well
glenn beck's still around
and uh
but you know i was talking about this
how like how many people in media are
like taking their resources and building
and trying to grow a network
and uh glenn beck
is like he's the guy doing that and then
i'm like we're doing that too so i
understand what you're saying you're
right about the foia task force we
already have two legal filings in for
two different 501c3s
the one thing i will say is a 501c3
can't do political journalism
because they're not allowed to engage in
political like campaigning stuff but
we're planning on doing fact checking
and um investigatory journalism through
the nonprofit we're also filing the the
open networking nonprofit which is going
to create open source networking tools
so that people can't be banned anymore
utilizing the fetiverse i'm sure all of
the wackos who use the fate of us are
very happy to hear that
all right
rick howell says
red blue right left are labels like man
and woman all can be generally defined
and generally true but all have
exceptions and corner cases arguing the
exceptions is valid but often not
worthwhile
interesting to be splitting hairs
all right let's see
blue sea says e and yes there are now
two sides there is no middle ask cubans
and venezuelans but why only two that's
my question why not seven hundred and
thousand you know because the cult is
massive
okay now that's a different situation
than two sides that's a big problem that
that's out there that we should all
focus on but that doesn't mean that it's
a side of a equation but it but it is so
like it's the the cult is is the borg
and then you have the federation the
romulans the cardassians and the
helpless and the klingons and they
really don't get along all that much but
when the board comes around it's like oh
man that's a big problem for everybody
maybe maybe the cardassians weren't a
good but the dominion weren't so worried
about the borg were they no the the uh
the dominion was a force that united the
other sides right yeah so that's a
better yeah good point the the cult is
the dominion in deep space nine and they
were like shape-shifting massive empire
and they were basically like they were
they were like the federation the
shape-shifters were in charge and then
they had all of their dominion right
their minions and so
the federation was losing and like on
the verge of collapse the romulans
refused to get involved the romulans
hate the federation but then they
eventually you know cisco effectively
tricked them well it was a great episode
where you got the romulans to join
inside but anyway that's the point like
whatever this side is it's comprised of
a bunch of small different factions with
the republican party probably as one of
the biggest components of it but i can't
stand the republican party for the most
part but there are a lot of people like
me who are probably left liberal
politically who think the cult is a
dangerous destructive borg force that
needs to be stopped so i'm willing to
vote for donald trump who says i'm going
to stop these things specifically and
promote values that will
prohibit this in the future and i'm like
we need to stop this
so
you know in the primary
two years ago i was like yang and tulsi
that i was yang had a huge list of
proposals it was brilliant like he went
through policy like no one i've ever
seen
too many of these people just bend the
knee to the borg as soon as as soon as
it comes down to it
so all right we'll just grab a couple
we'll just grab a couple more here
because we got to do the member segment
all right let's see
people are mentioning uh
illegal immigrants
d
c lenmiji celine maggie ian your
optimism is admirable we will not fix
the cult if peace is what we're after
then fine accept division and succession
to save the sovereignty of individuals
somewhere war will always be human
that was a powerful super chat
michael rutherford says i'm a leftist
and it's hilarious since we are saying
the same thing about you guys that you
have all been radicalized and need
deprogramming and that's the point yeah
we're objectively correct in that
well i don't know i don't think okay we
are i don't think either of us are
correct we are we're we're quite
literally correct when i can do research
and on and and look into the ukraine
meddling and the
and the uh corrupt actions of joe biden
and then look into the russia stuff and
be like hmm it seems like donald trump
is an [ __ ] he's got bad mannerisms
but he's not a racist he won civil
rights award he's an old man who's lewd
and lascivious i can accept all those
things because i looked into it joe
biden has a magazine article from
politico called biden inc that maps the
corruption of his family and then they
delete the news articles from twitter
proving that the sun's laptop you know
proving that hunter biden's laptop had
all this stuff on it and that he was
doing crack with hookers and that joe
biden was meeting with him and then tony
bobielinski comes out and says biden was
the big man he was getting cut in on the
deal and i'm like all those things
happened and all the news is there and
then they come out and say but you're in
a cult yo
i've been saying the entire time i get
into an uber uber and they're like man
trump is an [ __ ] isn't he i wish he
didn't talk the way he did but hillary
clinton she is evil
yes
there are a lot of people who are like
i'll put it this way
trump has his cult it's really small
they have no influence no influence and
no institutional power
so when the media highlights the fringe
as the boogeyman and says the alt-right
what did vox wrote an article saying the
alt-right could be as large as you know
40 million people or something like that
like somebody's saying put out a nbc
wrote a story it was brandy zadrasny
wrote a story in the spring about how
the lack of white supremacists at white
supremacy rallies was evidence of how
deep-seated white supremacy is in the
united states that there weren't white
supremacists there was the evidence yep
no but honestly that super chat is
amazing because like that's someone
calling themselves a leftist
willing to throw up a few bucks to to
say that yeah and like yeah it is true
that they're using the cult word as well
but
i think that it's it's pretty clear is
it yeah is it radicalization to be like
the founding fathers were right
the basis of our contract it's racist
the basis the basis of this country
that's been around for 250 years that we
learn in history class and it is regular
american culture is not radicalization
in any sense of the imagination the
radicalization is the me is is not the
media because this is media this is the
media as well it's the people who are
cheering for rule by decree and forced
medication on the americans i think it's
the media that's brainwashing those
people
is the is the focus not the people that
are getting brainwashed it's all there
that they end up yelling at they're
guilty it's social media and
establishment media yeah yep now it is
but these are all individuals who have
to make their own determinations and
decisions and are responsible for their
own views and their own actions so final
thought before we wrap up i will say
this the point i was making earlier
about the when when the conflict comes
these people genuinely believe that we
have all been radicalized that when i
have vosh a socialist on the show and
give him space to speak i'm somehow
radicalized yet other leftists won't
come on the show at all you want to talk
about radicalization it's that the only
leftists who beg to come on the show are
the ones who do drama bait and complain
about like
one guy is being roast like you know i'm
not gonna name anything i'm gonna find
one i'm gonna find a really good one i'm
gonna help help out with that mission i
have that here's the problem
i'll tell you this
on the right there are people with
millions of followers hundreds of
thousands have of of influence in the
intellectual dark web there are people
who are moderate or progressive of
influence they're all willing to have a
conversation in some capacity on the
left the high profile people in a cult
won't do it but the low profile people
desperate to build up followings will
beg to come on any platform that will
have them
so there's the issue so is there a
subscriber threshold that you're looking
for or a certain influence like like
mattering in the conversation
so
would it make sense if i went to like a
local dsa meeting and found a guy and
been like we'll put you on the show i
guess you're the best we could do
you know i i want someone who they're
like this guy said these things that
have an impact on the culture and i want
those ideas to be challenged and debated
alex jones is extremely influential why
won't anyone
be like i would gladly go on that show
to do it
there are some grifters who have a lot
of followers but their whole content
base is drama we don't we we want we
want political
conversations we don't want you smell
bad and you're dumb
and there are a lot of high profile
people that do that is that not this
course i mean
someone wanted to come on the show to
just sabotage the show i can't no
obviously i was making a joke so but
this is how it's always been i have a
video on my main channel from a long
time ago when i was in berkeley and i
was filming the street with my camera
when and talking to someone when a woman
inter inter
forced herself in the conversation and
started making a bunch of leftist points
so i turned with my camera and let her
speak then afterwards i asked her some
questions
and then what i basically said was a
woman was attacked she was bloody and
she goes well she deserved it you know
if she wants to come here wearing a maga
hat then she'll get attacked and i said
so you think that if a woman is wearing
skimpy clothing and a man attacks her
she shouldn't have once can be clothing
and she goes yeah and i was like okay
five minutes later you know uh like i'm
i turn the camera off i have the
recording she walks away don't use any
of that don't put that anywhere and i
was like
i was standing here and you started
saying things to me i have the footage
she's like no you can't use that
they don't want their ideas
they're scared that if they say the
wrong thing they'll get attacked the
left will come for them because it's a
cult meanwhile i can come out and argue
with glenn beck on his show about why
i'm pro-choice and it ends with us
shrugging shaking hands and saying that
was a really really great conversation
thank you so much
you don't get that on the left they
throw eggs at you they scream racial
slurs at people while they're wearing
gorilla masks well wearing gorilla masks
don't exit a black man and claim they're
not the racists you know
we'll wrap it up there i want to make
sure we get that member signing up for
you guys but thank you all so much for
watching smash that like button
subscribe to the channel go to
timcast.com share the show with your
friends you can follow me at timcast
everywhere you can follow the show at
steamcast irl you want to shout anything
out bill yeah everyone hit up mines
download the app download contest
minds.com mobile we got mine's token
battle going right now next person to a
thousand five thousand ten thousand a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
subs
gets so a hundred thousand subs gets ten
thousand tokens you know and
proportionally so if you if if you're if
you know the platform and you get a
thousand followers do you get a hundred
tokens not everybody the next person
next person the next person so there's
one winner for each right now we're
going to keep doing this 100 tokens is
like 200 bucks yeah
oh that's cool so
i'm like 20 k away from 200 000
followers on mine
and it's 20 000 tokens
yeah that's like 40 grand
wow
subscribe to him on mines yeah yeah well
sargon's fighting you oh is he actively
getting followers or he's aware he's
aware
minds.comcast 40 grand we could hire
somebody with that we sure could just
hire somebody 40 grand for the year to
do some something i guess full stack
libby you want to shout someone out oh
it's not for 40 grand a year
[Laughter]
hey well you could follow me on mines
apparently oh um i have it i keep
forgetting my password but i'm gonna
nail that at some point uh my name's
libby emmons i'm on twitter at libby
emmons and i'm at the post-millennial
every day
i'm uh ian crossland and you are
sovereign
oh
this is good to know i will say before
we go that i i appreciate ian's concept
of not trying to divide people into
groups but i will say that there comes a
point when people are dividing you
against them and you don't have a choice
anymore and if they're putting you into
a group like unvaccinated or in my
instance it would be something like
pro-life something they will really come
after me for i don't have a choice we're
not on the same team it's unfortunate
but it's the way it is anyway for hot
takes like that you guys are more than
welcome to follow me on twitter at sour
patch lids i'm only two thousand away
from
outstripping sour patch kids that's my
only goal in life so please follow me
there that's a big one i'll give one
final shout out to michael rutherford
who responded
saying tim you are just as delusional as
the people you hate
i would say that
i don't hate
99.999 of people there are journalists
who work for websites like buzzfeed and
vox and the daily beast and slate who
are evil people who make things up and
lie
now as for the delusional thing i'll
tell you this when michael brzezinski
goes on her show and says our job is to
tell people what to think you can think
whatever you want about what she said
sure
when i can read a story from politico
that says ukraine scrambles after
aiding the democrats in the 2016
election
and then later writes another article
saying there was no meddling from
ukraine in the election i have to wonder
why politico didn't just retract the
first article how both things can be
true
when you have
four years of russiagate that i accepted
in the press and said wow look at this
evidence i actually met with a very high
profile journalist who told me all this
stuff and i was like man it sounds like
trump did this and then the news comes
out it didn't happen it was bunk it was
a witch hunt all that stuff the fbi
report says no when the fbi comes out
and says there was no coordinated
insurrection and there was no plan i got
to say how many times are you willing to
be wrong or if the fact is you don't
actually research anything you don't
look into the stories you don't fact
took any of them how about mayo gate
when slate huffington post i don't know
if it was slave but haven't posted the
independent published a story claiming
that republicans were lying about the
cost of mayonnaise and i simply called
the restaurant and got the confirmed
numbers you call it delusional doing the
ground work to figure out the facts you
are delusional my friend timcast.com
we'll see you all there
you